For decades, the Perl programming language has remained important in the realms of text processing,
system administration, and even web development. Learn how to use Perl in this complete course
for beginners. This course covers topics ranging from basic syntax to advanced topics like object
oriented programming, regular expressions, and web development. Walters has been using
Perl for years, and he will teach you how to use the language in your own projects.
Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this course section, we will be mostly working with
Perl script files. However, before we proceed with looking at Perl file structure, I just
want to quickly show you how you can run Perl through command line interface. Now, in order
to run Perl through command line interface, you can type Perl space minus e for execute,
then single quotes or double quotes. I usually tend to use single quotes because with double
quotes, you can interpolate variables. And let's use single quotes for this example.
And let's do something like print, which is going to print something to a terminal,
double quotes, so they don't interfere with or wrapping single quotes of our Perl code
and say hello. And let's also add a backslash n and a backslash n is simply a new line.
So if you run this by hitting return, we're going to see hello printed to our terminal.
Now, the alternative how you can run this is with capital E. And what capital E does is simply
enables some of the pro core features. We're going to look at some of these features in
next lectures. But for now, let's explore a very simple and handy one, which is called say,
and this say feature is simply adding a new line at the end of whatever we're printing.
So if we run this code again, we're going to see hello, new line followed by another new line.
So it's all automatically adding a new line at the end of whatever we're printing. Now, if we
remove this new line, which we added in the string, we're just going to see a single new line,
which is printed after or hello. If I would try to run this with lowercase, I'm going to see an
error. And that's going to say that there is something wrong at line one. And if we forgot
to declare say, well, technically, yes, we didn't declare say and the say command wasn't recognized
because we didn't enable features. So pro didn't know what say means. And what did this supposed
to do? You might be wondering, why would this be useful in general? Why would I be running these
one liners? Well, sometimes writing full script file might be an overkill. Maybe you just want to
quickly pour some input via pro. In this case, writing a script file is probably not the best
solution. Just to give more elaborate example, and don't worry about the syntax, we will look at it
in the future lectures. But let's do something like Perl minus C, let's do capital E, then single
quotes, where we can add our pro code, let's say while, which is a loop, and then opening and
closing parentheses. Let's add this diamond operator, which is taken an input, then opening
and curly braces for executing or while block logic. And let's add something like say, you see
or upper case, and let's use this dollar sign underscore. And this dollar sign underscore is
simply the current context, the while loop is receiving and what we are working on. So, but to
put it simple, it's a while loop, which takes an input from our terminal, it runs indefinitely,
and is going to print whatever we're giving or script, and uppercasing it. Well, it's uppercasing
it and then printing it out. So if we run this, we're going to see that nothing happens. And this
is because our program now is waiting for an input. But if I do something like Hello, lowercase,
it's returned, I'm going to see uppercase Hello printed out. And that's what I talked about
basically our program runs text and input, it uppercases the input and prints it out. Now,
of course, there can be 100 of other more useful scenarios, such as listing files, parsing file
names, replacing file extensions, so on and so on. The scenarios really depends on the use case.
But now you know how you can run pro through command line interface if ever you need to.
I hope you found this lecture useful. And I'll see you at the next one.
Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video, we will explore a basic pro script file
structure. Let's begin. Here I am currently in my Visual Studio Code editor, and I have opened up
an empty folder. If you're using Visual Studio Code as well, you can open up a folder by going to file
and choosing open folder. From there, you will get a file explorer pop up and you can navigate
to the directory in which you want to work in. Let's create a new pro script file. You can do
this by right clicking in an empty space in your Visual Studio Code editor and choosing new file.
Alternatively, as another example, you could create a file using touch command by opening
Visual Studio Code terminal and writing touch followed by the file name. To open Visual Studio
Code terminal, you can tap control till there on your Mac or go to view terminal. Or of course,
by any other means, if you're not using Visual Studio Code editor, I'm going to create a file
through the editor and name it script.pl. The first thing to note is that you end your pro script
files with dot.pl extension. I will start out by writing the full basic profile structure and
afterwards we will go into detail of what each line means. So let's begin. Hashtag exclamation
mark, user, bin, environment, curl, use strict, use warnings, it's printed. Hello world,
semicolon one, semicolon and new one. Okay, a lot of things are going on here for a very basic pro
script file. But don't worry, we will go through each line and explore in detail what it means.
Before that, let's quickly see how we can run this file. If you go to a terminal and type
curl, followed by the script file name, which in this case is script.pl, you're going to see
hello world printed to your console. This line comes from the print statement we added in our
script file. But what about the other lines? Well, the first line at the top is called shebang
line. And it basically tells your system how to run this file if the file is set as executable,
you can run your file as executable. If you go back to your console and type dot forward slash
script, which is or pro script file name, and press return. By default, you're going to see
a warning that says permission denied. And that is because currently or file is not set as
executable. You can see this by typing LS for list minus LA and or file name, which is script.pl.
And what we see here that or file is currently set as read and write water missing is the
executable tag. To set your file as executable, you can write schmod, which is for change mode,
plus x and the file name, which is or script.pl and press return. Now if you type LS minus LA
or script name, which is script.pl, you're going to see this new x tag, which means this file
should now be executable. If we try to rerun dot forward slash script.pl and note that we did not
add pro before the script file name is going to bring Hello World. The interesting thing
is that if we remove the shebang line at the top of our file, we save it, go back to our console,
and try to run our script as executable. It's going to complain. This is because our system
does not know that this file should be executed as a pro script and tries to run it as a bash
script. Therefore, it complains that the content of this file could not be parsed. And that is the
meaning of the shebang line. It basically tells your system how to run this file, if your file
is set as executable, and you did not explicitly specify that it should be run as a pro script.
So if you add this line back, we save it, we rerun it, and it works again. The next two lines
starting with use are called pragmas. There are various pragmas in pro. However, the most standard
ones you should always be using are use strict and use warnings. In essence, these statements
enforce you to write robust and less error prone code. They give you warnings and even compile
time errors when you are trying to write pro code that can cause ambiguous results. Let's test this
by firstly commenting out the use statements. In Visual Studio Code, you can highlight multiple
lines of text and tap command forward slash, which is going to automatically comment your pro code.
Next, let's try to join our Hello World string with a variable in our print statement.
And don't worry if this looks confusing. We will look at variable types in our next lectures along
with concatenating and interpolating variables in strings. However, let's just focus on the fact
that this strange variable came out of nowhere. It has no value and we're trying to randomly append
it to our string with a dot notation. What we're doing might seem wrong and ambiguous. And that is
because it is. We should not be able to use something we haven't defined in our scripts. However,
pro is not going to complain unless you tell it to complain. If we try to rerun our script with
explicitly saying pro or script name, which is script dot PL is going to say Hello World.
And this is where the strict and warning progress come into play. It will explicitly tell our pro
script not to allow such ambiguity in our code. If we uncomment warnings and try to run our code
again, we're seeing more output. And this output is main test used only once main referring to
our package, which is this file, possibly a typo on a script PL. Yeah, close enough. And it says
use initialize value or sign test in concatenation. And that is true. We are using an initialized
value in concatenation with our string Hello World. Now, if we try to uncomment strict, save the file,
run it again. Pearl, script dot PL is going to say global symbol test requires explicit package
name. Did you forget to declare my test? Well, yes, we did not declare my test variable. And then it
says execution of script appeal aborted due to compilation errors. And this is great. Now,
instead of just giving warnings or script actually bails out and says, no, no, no, I don't know what
this variable is. I don't want to proceed compiling this I don't want to run this. Please be more
explicit with your code. Now let's try to define our variable before using it. So if I say my
best equals a random value, which is a random string. And we save this. And I understand if
this might seem confusing at this point, because we haven't looked into variables and how you
define them. But a short summary is that basically, we have this simple scalar, which are going to look
into next lectures, that we assign a string, which is called random. And then we try to concatenate
it with our hello world. Now, when we have explicitly defined our variables, and we try
to rerun our code is going to succeed, what we're going to see now is or random, which is the test
variable concatenated with hello world. Now, finally, the print statement, as you probably
have guessed by now, simply prints out a text to our console. Lastly, we are returning a number.
This is a standard for pro script, but not necessarily always present. It's common to
return a truthy value in your pro scripts to indicate that the compilation of your pro script
succeeded. If you have a standalone pro script, as we do now, the truthy return value will probably
not be in place. However, and we will look into this in use versus require section, if not set,
the script will throw a warning when you are using a pro script in another pro script.
But that's it for this lecture. We looked at the basic pro script file layout and what is the
meaning of the shebang line along with the strict and warning progress. I hope you found this video
useful. And I'll see you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this
video, we're going to explore one of pros data structures scalars. Let's begin. So what are
scalars? Well, scalars are single unit of data, meaning they can hold one off undefined number,
decimal number, string or reference. But don't worry about reference for now. You define a
scalar by saying my dollar sign, let's say test equals one. So we assign a number of value one
to a variable scalar named test. As mentioned before, you can also assign let's say my string
equals hello, and as well as assigning my decimal equals 1.22. So one thing to note is that scalar
names are unique. So if I try to save my test equals one, save this, and I try to run it in
my console by pro script.pl is going to say my variable test marks earlier declaration in same
scope. And what this means is basically it's saying that hmm, looks like you did define a variable
named test. And you're trying to define a variable, which is called test again, you might be doing
something wrong. And in this case, this is quite true. We are defining my test variable twice.
And it does not make a lot of sense. On that note, it's worth mentioning that the variables are also
case sensitive. So if I said my capital test equals one, save this, run the pro script.pl.
I'm going to see no warnings. And this is because I have a test variable defined with a lowercase
t. And another variable called test with the same value but defined with capital T. So technically,
the variable names are not the same, because one is with a lowercase t and the other one is with
the uppercase t. Let's look at some variable operations. Let's start out with the numbers.
For example, I'm going to remove string for now. And I am going to print out a test plus
decimal, both console printed out, I'm saying 2.22. So what we did there, we added test variable
value one with decimal variable value 1.22. And what we got in the end is 2.22. We can also do
the same thing with this subtraction. So if I say test minus decimal, I go back to the console,
I rerun the script file, what I'm going to see is minus 0.22. And that makes sense because one
minus 1.22 equals minus 0.22. You can also do multiplication, which is one times 0.122,
rerun this, and it's the same as 1.22. And you can do division as well. So this, which is one
divided by 1.22, go to the console, you know, rerun the Perl script file, you're going to see
a very ambiguous number. But let's just assume this is right. Probably it's going to make more
sense if we say test equals 20. And we divide it by five, which should give us four. And yes,
here we go. We see number four printed out to our console. Now let's look at the strings,
let's reintroduce our variable name string equals. Oh, there are a couple of things you can do with
the strings. For example, so if I have a string variable, so variable name string, and number two
equals hello two, I can print out string and concatenate it with this dot notation with
string two. Save this, rerun our Perl script file, I'm going to see hello concatenated with
hello two. Well, another thing I can do with strings is I can interpolate them. For example,
I could convert string two with the whole quotation marks and say hello to space string variable,
save this. And I'm going to replace the print statement only string to save this,
go to the console, run pro script.pl. And I'm going to see hello to value, which comes from here,
space, and the value of string, you can also use special variables in your strings, such as a break
line, you might have noticed that in our console, usually when we run our script, we're going to end
up with the terminal input at the end of what we printed, it's not quite great. So what we probably
want to introduce is a new line. And how you can add a new line is by adding backslash n, we save
this, we rerun our script. And what you're going to see now, this is the value we printed out,
followed by new line. So my terminal input is on the next line. One thing to note, this is only
usable when you're using double quotes, this will not work for single quotes. What I mean is,
if I would say backslash n, in my variable string, and I would try to print this out,
what I'm actually going to see is the hello to value, which we see here, and the variable hello,
which holds hello backslash n, which is just a string. So you cannot use these special variables
in strings which have single quotation marks. You can also use special variables such as backslash
t, which stands for tab, we rerun or pro script file. And what we're going to see is there is a
slight extra break here, but it's not that quite visible. So if we add, let's say, two more
backslashes, and rerun the file, yes, this is much more visible, we can see that we have inserted
tabs here. So let's try to concatenate a number with a string. So I'm going to remove the string
two, and I'm going to say my scalar, and let's call it a number, just a scalar name equals one.
And we try to print out string, concatenated with variable number. Let's also add that
break line here, which is backslash n. And let's run this so pro script.pl. And what we're going
to see here is the hello value, which is in the string, because we left the backslash n here,
and followed by number one. So when you're trying to concatenate a string with a number,
pro is going to be smart enough to understand what you actually want to do, you want to
convert the number to string and concatenate that together. But what happens if we try to,
let's say, some variable number and variable string? Let's do that. Let's replace string
dot notation for which is concatenation with plus. And let's still leave the dot backslash n
for the new line. And let's say that let's go back to the console, rerun it. And it's going to say
argument hello isn't numeric in addition. So this means that pro is smart enough to figure out that
you're trying to use a number which is in variable number. And you're trying to add it to a variable
called string, which holds a string. And it doesn't seem quite right, because you are trying to sum up
a string with a number. One final thing to add is, for example, if you wanted to print a double
quoted string, such as hello, and use a variable, let's say number, but you don't really want to
print out the value of this variable. But you literally want to say hello, dollar sign number.
So you can do this by backslash before the variable sigil, and it's going to escape your
variable in the double quotes. Let's save this, go back to the console, set Perl script at PL.
And here we go, we see hello, dollar sign number. So this variable number one wasn't
interpreted inside the double quoted string. So hopefully it's a lot clearer what is a scaler in
Perl, how you create and assign values to scalers, including doing some basic operations such as
adding numeric values and concatenating strings. I hope you found this video useful, and I'll see
you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. Before we move towards exploring
other data types in Perl, I would like to introduce you to an alternative and much better way to
debug your pro code instead of using print statements. This alternative is using a module
called data dumper. And how you can use it is by saying, use data, colon colon, dumper,
semicolon. To note, you do not need to explicitly install this module as long as you're using
pro version 5.36 or above, meaning this module is part of pro default core modules. And to be more
precise, the data dumper module should be available from pro version 5.20. Later in this section,
we will explore in more detail how to install and use modules, along with how to use statement
works behind the scenes. However, for now, the key takeaway is that when we write this
use data dumper, we get access to a powerful debugging method called dumper. And how we can
invoke this is by saying, print, dumper, opening bracket and closing bracket, and ending with
semicolon. So everything what we put in between the bracket is going to get debugged in our terminal.
So basically, this method, aka dumper function takes a list of arguments, and will print out
detailed information about the given data. Let's try it out by printing some data about scalar
variables, I'm going to introduce a scalar, a variable called a, which is going to hold a string
and it's going to say hello, and English semicolon. And I'm also going to introduce a variable called
b, which is going to hold a decimal, let's say 22.32. And then that, and now I'm going to add
these variables in between the dumper function. So lower sign a comma, lower sign b, save this,
go to the console and write URL, script.pl. And what I'm going to see is this var one currently
holds hello, and variable two holds 22.32. And what this refers to is that variable one,
var one, is the position of the variable being debugged. In this case, the var one refers to
lower sign a, which holds a value of a string, which says hello, not the var two at position two
holds a value of 22.32, which we can see here, you might be thinking, well, this does not differ
much from what we saw in our previous lectures using print. And you are right. At the current
time, it does not differ much. And that is because we're using basic data types, such as strings and
numbers. However, the real power of this debugging module will become much more apparent, the more we
use it in our future lectures, with more complicated data structures like arrays, hashes and references.
So this is it for this lecture, we looked at how we can use the data dumper debugging module,
I hope you found this video useful, and I'll see you at the next one.
Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video, we're going to explore the second pro
data type array. So what is an array? Array is a data type that holds order list of values.
These values can be strings, numbers, decimals and references. But as before,
don't worry about the references at this point. Quick note, lists and array are often used as if
they're the same. But the list is the data you assign to array and array is the actual variable.
Or you can create an array is by saying my at symbol test equals branches and semicolon.
Let's try to debug it now as we did before. So let's say print dumper. And in between there,
we're going to add our test, we're going to end it with semicolon, go back to our console, save
pro to appeal, and we're gonna get nothing. And this is normal because we haven't added anything
into or array yet. Let's do that next. Let's introduce couple of values such as a number,
let's say 22, a string, which is gonna say Hello, and a decimal, let's say 1.22. Let's save it up.
Let's go back to our console. Let's rerun the pro script appeal. And what we're going to see now
is that the variable remember on the left hand side, these are positions 123, and the values
being 22 Hello, 1.22. So what happened here, since this is a list, we got all the elements
printed other positions, as we have defined in our list sequence. So variable one is 22 variable
two is Hello, and variable three is 1.22. Such as we can see here. Now alternative way, if you're
using with only strings and single words, what you can do is you can use this keyword called
q w, which is for vault board, and followed by forward slashes and say 123. Now if you
debug that, we're going to see 123. And this is quite a handy shortcut instead of using parentheses,
quoting your strings. If you only need strings in your list, and those strings are not separated
by spaces, such as 123. And then you want to add a single string, which is my for what you end up
with is actually five items in the list. So 123 my being a separate item, because it's separated
by space, and then followed by four. Now in order to access or items in a list, and I'm going to
remove this by keyword, so we have 123, you can use dollar sign, followed by your list name,
which is going to be test square brackets, and the position of element in your list. Now take note
here that all the positions of items in an array starts at zero, meaning the string one is going
to be at position zero, string two is going to be at index position one, three at index position
two, and four at index position three, it might seem confusing. But basically, just think about it,
how many items you have in your list, just add minus one. And that's how you can access it. So
for example, if I wanted to access, let's say, string of three, I can do four sign test square
brackets, and index position of two. There this go to the console, I printed out which is pro
script.pl. And here we go, we can see variable equals three, because you're accessing the index
position two, which is 012 holds a string of three, you can also override items in your list
by using the same notation of index. So let's say I'm going to remove this, I'm going to still
print out the test. And I'm going to say test. And let's say I want to override the item at position
three, which should be your string four. And I want to say that this is now override, save this
with our console printed out. And what I'm going to see now is 123 and override, because we override
the variable, which is a position index three, meaning for with a new string override. Now the
interesting thing is that let's say I wanted to add an item at position 10. I'm going to say
test position 10 is override. Now I'm going to print out the list. And what I'm going to see
is now that we have 1234 represented by items here. And then we have these undefined values that we
looked at in the previous lecture, which means it has no value at these positions. And then the
11th item, which is minus one, index, and is override, which we just said now. Now what if
I wanted to access this last item in the list? So instead of needing to know how many items and the
index positions I have in the list, what I can do, I can say minus one. And actually, let's say that
I wanted to not introduce a new item at position minus one, but I'm going to say test. And I want
to access minus one, which should be the item for at the end of the list. If I save this, print this
out. And here we go. I see variable position one is a value of four. The same goes if I wanted to
access minus three is going to be 123, which should be value of two, I save this up. And I debug this
and I see that the value printed out is two, a little bit confusing, because if we want to
access items at the end of array, we actually need to start at position minus one, if you want to
access items from the first position, it starts at zero, it's just something to keep in mind. Now
another thing you might want to know is how many items you have in the list. And the way how you
can do this is by saying my, let's say define a variable size equals a test. Now if you print out
the test, go to our console, we're going to see that oops, we have to do we actually have a variable
defined a size apologies, we save this, we run the pro script again, and we're going to see that
it's four. And that's right, because we have 1234 items in our array, which is called test.
Now here, what happens is that since we're trying to assign a list to a scalar, we're actually
implying a scalar context, right? Because a scalar can hold a single unit of data, it cannot hold a
list. So what it's going to do is going to take the list size and assign the number of items to
the size variable. So another thing you might want to know you want to know what is the last index
in our array, the way how you can do this is by saying last, let's say it was defined a variable
of last decks equals dollar sign hashtag is going to be the name of our list, which is test.
And now if we print out last index, we go to the terminal, parallel script.pl, we're going to see
three. And that is correct, because the index is three, we have four items, as we debug before,
the last index is three, because we started zero. So 0123. Now let's look at some very useful
methods how we can quickly populate arrays using sequential numbers, or letters. Let's say I want
to populate my list with numbers from 11 to 30. You can go 1234. And well, I mean, that's actually
111213. And so on. But there is a shortcut and a lot much quicker way you can say 11 dot dot 30.
30. Now we said this, and what we actually want to print out is this list, we override that go to
console printed. And what we're going to see is that our array get automatically populated with
numbers from 11 till 30. So all the way down from here, at position one, up to position 20,
you can do the same thing with letters. Let's say I wanted to populate the array with letters from
A1 to Z. I go to the terminal, I print this, and here we go. A, B, C, D, so on, and up to Z. And you
can of course also do like age and just go to N. You got console print this so G, H, I, J, K, L, M,
N. So let's say I only wanted to access specific elements in my list that contains numbers one,
two, three, four. I can do this by saying the variable name, which is array name test,
and I can give index positions. So if I wanted to access only the elements three and four,
I can go zero, one, two, three. So if I say two dot dot three, save this, save pro,
save dot PL, I'm going to see three and four. Because index position two is zero, one, two,
and index position three is four. There are four commonly used methods when working with arrays.
Let's explore them in more detail. Let's keep our list in a place. And let's say I just want
to debug the list itself. And I'm going to write them out the methods which are commonly used,
which are push, pop, shift, and unshift. So what the push does, it adds an element at the end of
the array. For example, if I say push, you provide the array name, which is best. And let's say I
want to add number 20, save this. And I print out my items and I see 123 for an or new item,
which is 20. Now pop removes an element from the end of the array. So if I say pop,
array name, which is test and this, and I reprint, I'm going to see 123 for,
which is just original list. Now shift is going to remove the first item from the list.
If I say shift at test, save this, rerun, and I see two, three, four, because or item one that's
removed. Now unshift is going to do the opposite of shift, which you can imagine is it's adding
an element at the beginning of the list. So on shift, let's say at test 20, save this and reprint,
we're going to say 2234. But because we pushed an item on the list, we removed an item from the end
of the list, we shifted an item from beginning of list, which was one, and then we added an item at
beginning of the list, which is 20. So another useful thing you can do with your list is sort them.
And by default, pro has this sort method, but it works with strings by default. So let's
look at example of sorting strings using sort method. So I say, H, O, P, M, L, A, B, C,
space here. So to sort this list, you want to say at test, you want to replace this list with
a sorted value, which is sort. And you simply provide a list because as I mentioned, the sort
method by default works on strings. If we try to sort this test list, we should get back the
expected results. I would save this, go to our console, save pro, kib.po, going to be a, b,
c, d, h, l, m, o, p. That looks all right, because we had a h, o, p, m, and so on and so on. And this
does look like a sorted list of letters. Now what if we want to sort a numeric list? So let's remove
this, let's introduce four to 10, 22, and maybe 30. If I try to say test, sort, test, and print
this out. So something does happen. It says 10 to 2234. But it does not look quite what we would
expect. And this is because it's actually sorting these numbers based on a string context. What we
want is to explicitly define a function after the sort method, which we're going to say, a,
doing the first element what we received in this method, this comparison symbol, which is also
referred to as spaceship symbol, and value b, which is the next item we're going to iterate over.
I save this, go back to the console, and I print this out again. And I see two, four, 10, 22,
30. You can also reverse this by saying b, and a, save this, reprint, and it's going to be 30,
22, 10, and so on. In the next lectures, we're also going to explore additional methods as join,
split, grip, and map in pro built in function section. So these are definitely, by any means,
the only functions we have to work on lists. But this is it for this lecture, we looked at what
are arrays in pro, how you create and fetch values in arrays. And we also looked at basic
methods to interact with arrays in pro. I hope you found this video useful, and I'll see you at
the next lecture. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video, we're going to explore the
funnel pro data type, which is called a hash. So what is a hash? A hash is simply a set of key
value pairs, you store and access your values in a hash using keys. The values in the hash can be
strings, numbers or references. But as I have said, you don't need to worry about references
at this point. hashes are an excellent solution if you need a fast look of values, if you know
the key, think of it as a phone book, but faster, of course. So basically, you have person's name,
and you would like to look up their phone number, you can have 1000s of entries in hash, and quickly
look it up using a key. Let's look at example to make this clearer. To declare a hash, you can say
my percentage sign, let's call it a map equals parentheses. Now let's try to debug it. So print
number and or hash, David, we go to console role script.pl, we're going to see nothing. So as before,
since we don't have any values, we are not seeing anything in our console. Let's change that. Let's
say I wanted to add a key, which is a is going to point to a number, let's say 20, a key B, which
is going to point to a string, which is hello, and key C, which is going to point to 11.22.
If I save this, go back to the console, and I rerun the pro script, what I'm going to see is
actual least values. So positions being 123456, a 20 C, 11, 22, and B, hello. And this is because
technically hash is a list that has elements following order of key, comma, value. Now the
thing to note is that this list is never going to have the same order. As you can see already here,
we have item A with value 20, as we have defined in or hash. However, the next value is C, 1122,
which should be B, hello. And it's not a case, because the order is never going to be preserved
in a hash. If I rerun this again, I'm going to see C, 1122, a 20. And if I rerun, you can see as
before the order changes all the time. If we want to access a specific key in our hash, it's very
similar to array. So we're going to use dollar sign, the name of for hash, which is map. But instead
of using square brackets, we're going to use curly brackets, go like this. And then we're going to
give our key, which in this case can be let's say C, we save this, we rerun and we see now what we
debug the variable one, which holds a value of 11.22. If you want to set a new value, we can do
the same thing very similar to arrays. But we're going to use dollar map instead of square brackets,
then use curly brackets. And instead of the position of our element, we want to add, we're
going to say, we want to add a new key, which is ABCD equals new. Now, if we print out the D key,
we're going to say new. One important thing about hashes is that the keys are unique, meaning you
cannot have more than one key with the same name in your hash. So what I mean by that is that if I
remove what I debug before, replace it with dollar hash, that this and let's say I wanted to add C
equals two, and C equals, let's say a string new, I save this, and I debug my hash. And what I'm
going to see is that C holds a value of new. And this is important, because we have three key value
pairs in our hash. But what is preserved is the latter value in the hash. So all the keys,
which come before the final key with the same name, is going to be overridden, meaning this
is original key, which was overridden by C with value two, and then overridden again by C new.
On the same topic, it's worth mentioning the keys are unique. So what you could have,
you can have a capital C, which points to a value new. If we save this, we print out our
key value list, we're going to see capital C equals new. And alongside that, we're going to see or
lowercase c 11.22. As for the key names, you can have letters or numbers or underscores in your
key names. However, once you want to start introducing special characters such as percentage
sign or a space, what you need to do you actually have to wrap your key name with a quote. So if
we save this, and we debug our hash, we're going to see or key of one underscore percentage sign
space, or the value of new. And if we remove these quotes, and save this, well, you might imagine
this probably going to be invalid syntax. And that is true, because we see misplaced underscore
syntax error at percentage sign. And it gets very confusing. Something's very, very wrong.
Another useful thing to know is that you can merge two hashes together. Let's say I have my map with
some values. And let's remove this one, which is breaking our script, we save this and let's say
my map two equals new hash, I'm going to say I have keys low, which points to number one,
and I'm going to add percentage sign and math, save this, and I'm going to debug map two.
So what we're going to have here is our original keys pointing to our values, plus the hello one,
which is going to point to hello one. This is how you can merge multiple hashes together. And you
can even explicitly override the values in the hash, saying, I want the C to be new.
By debug, the C holds the value of new now. What happened here, we had our original hash,
we merged it into the second hash, we spread the values, so to say, and then we override the value
of C, which is 11.22 with a new value, which is string new. So similar as with arrays, you can
also access slices of hashes. For example, let's remove the second array and let's print out the
first array, but save it and how you access specific slices of a hash is by using at symbol
before your hash name curly brackets, and then the name of the keys. For example, if I wanted to
access a and C, I would say a comma C save this. And if I print out, sorry, let's use the quotation
marks. And if I print this out, I'm going to see value of 20, and a value of 1122. Because I'm
accessing slice of a with value 20, and slice of C of value 1122. Now let's explore some very
useful methods that's going to help you to work with hashes. So one of these methods is called
keys. And as you can imagine, it does exactly that it returns the keys of the hash. Now let's say I
want to introduce a new array, which is my array. And I'm going to say keys for center sign map,
which is our hash name, save this. And what I'm going to debug is the actual array named array.
And we go to our console, we print this out and we see the AC. And because the keys method
returns all the keys of a hash, and the hash keys are never sorted, they're always changing,
we're going to get back random order of the keys. So we started with BAC, now it's ACB, and so on,
and so on. The keys method is also very useful if you want to get the size of the hash. So my size
equals ease, and the name of the hash. Now very similar what we saw with array is that here we
have scalar context. And we say I want to see how many keys there are in the map hash. So we're
going to get back all the keys in this map, as I saw before, what we are imposing a scalar context.
So this becomes a list where the scalar context is imposed. So what we should get back now is the
amount of keys, aka the size of the hash, which is three. So another thing is that, for example,
if you want to see if a key exists in a hash, what you want to avoid checking condition where
it could be false, for example, ABCD equals on depth, you can use a keyword called exists.
And how we can check if the key exists is you can use a ternary expression. And don't worry
about this now, we will look into ternary expression later on. But basically, we can
check the existence of the value by saying exists is just a scalar name equals exists.
This is the function where we say, or map hash. Since we try to access a value, we use dollar
notation, we want to check for key, which is called D. And the ternary statement goes with
question mark, which says, is this first expression true? If this is true, then we say, yes. And then
you use colon, which is if this expression is not true, which is going to call the string of no.
Now we can print out the exists. This goes to the console printed out and it says yes,
it does exist. If you wouldn't use this keyword, and we remove the exists, we printed out is going
to say no, because well, technically, our key does exist in or hash. However, since we are
checking on a truthy context, and in pro undefined is not a truthy truthy value would be one or a
string or a positive number. But in this case, we're using a depth, which is not truthy value.
And that's why the exists keyword is quite useful, because it says, okay, well, do we have the key?
We don't care about the value, but do we have it in our hash? And in this case, yes, we do have it.
If we say, do we have a key of z, save this printed out? No, we don't have key of z.
And the final useful method worth mentioning is delete, I could delete items from my hash.
And how I can delete items from my hash is, I'm going to remove this statement, I'm going to print
out my hash. This I can call delete. As before, we use dollar notation access a single element in
our hash. So I'm going to say or sign map, and I can say delete, see, I save this, rerun the script.
And as you see, there's no more C here, we have DB and a, I can repeat this line by saying also
remove a and also remove the if I reprint this, here we go, we only have B left in our hash.
This is it for this video. We looked at what are hashes in Perl, or you can create an access
values in a hash. And we also explore basic operations on the hash structure. I hope you
found this video useful, and I'll see you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture.
In this video, we're going to explore what are references. I've said multiple times in previous
lectures that you should not worry about references. However, that has changed. We have
come to the point where we do have to worry about references. But don't feel intimidated.
The more you work with references, the more it becomes clearer what they are,
how they work, and how extremely powerful they are. So what is a reference? Well, reference is
basically a location in memory, which points to another data structure, such as array, hash, or
scalar. Reference allow you to construct nested data structures, such as hashes where keys point
to nested reference like array or hash reference, or arrays that contain reference to hash or array
reference at set position. I understand if this also is confusing, but don't worry. Just think of
it that previously when we were merging arrays and hashes, we could not be able to point a key to a
hash, because our hash gets automatically merged in our, so to say, normal data structure, which is
array or hash. With references, you can actually nest the hash structure or array structure,
which can be very, very useful in a lot of scenarios. You might have also heard of a term
passing by value or passing by reference. When you pass data in your code using value,
you're duplicating the data in memory and allocating new memory space for your values.
When you pass by reference, you're actually passing the location of data structure in memory
instead of copying the data. Passing by reference can be extremely useful if you want to work with
the same data reference in your code, instead of constantly copying your data all over. Let's look
at some examples. What I have in front of me is a simple hash, which is named hash. And it holds a
key A and B, which points to values one and two respectively. I also have array, which is defined
with this quote forward syntax and holds string one, string two, and I have a scalar, which simply
holds a number 32. Now to get references to these values, we can use the special syntax, which is
using a backslash before your data structure. What I mean is if I try to do print, I can say backslash
hash, save this up, but console run my pearls script at PL. And I'm going to see this strange
value. And basically, this is a reference in memory, it says that what they're printing out here
is a reference in memory, instead of actually printing out the hash, you could try to print
out the hash as it is, like this, we can see B to A one, which is basically a list printed out,
B being the key, and two being a value and a key and one value, the same would be with array,
right? So if we say array, if we print out array, we're just going to print out the values there
string one string two. Now, if we add a backslash before the array, we're actually going to see
this syntax is going to say, hey, what you're working with here is array references. And this
is the point in the memory for this reference. And this point in the memory is not going to change.
So if we say, for example, print many array references, we're going to see that maybe let's
add a new line character, so it's better formatting. So what I'm doing now on Mac is I'm pressing
option command and down arrow to select multiple lines, space double quotes, because we want to
use special characters, and then save this, go to the console, print it out. And you're going to see
that all of these values are actually the same, it says it's a hash ref. And this is the point in
the memory, we printed it out many times, but it never changed. Because this array has been already
allocated in the memory. And all of these references are pointing to the same allocation of the data
structure. Now, let's look at some example where we are sending a reference to a scalar, then we're
trying to modify that reference. Let's do this, let's create my ref one equals backslash, let's
choose array and do my ref two and backslash array. And let's do this, let's try to push something on
this reference one, because well, it should be a hash ref one. And let's say, string new, just for
new string, we go to console, and we try to run this is going to say, you're trying to push a
something on a scalar, which is forbidden. And the thing is that when you're trying to manipulate
references, you always have to dereference your reference before working with them. So basically,
what it means you have to get a regional data structure back in order to push or pop or access
an element and so on. So referencing was using backslash before or data structure dereferencing
is well, you can actually do it many ways. One of my preferred ways is I use arrow syntax as such.
And then I say that this is array. And you use this asterisk, you save it. And you press run it
and it didn't complain because we are dereferencing this and trying to push a new string, which is
fine, because we can use push method on array. Now let's also do this, let's try to print out
what we are actually getting back in array. So print, dumper, oh, dumper. And let's print out
the array. Let's save this, go to the console, run this again. And here we go, we see string one and
string two. And we also see our new value. So as you can see, we pushed on to a reference that we
dereference so we can, you know, push things on it. And we added the new value. And now we have
three values on the array, we could do the same thing for reference two, right? We could try to
push, let's say, new to go back to console, print this out. And here we go. So we have our two
original values in our array, which were defined here, then we have references, reference one,
reference two, apologies, which points to the same data structure in a memory. So basically
reference one and reference two holds the same pointer in memory that says, Hey, this is this
array. And then we are using this reference to say, Hey, add this value to this structure
in memory. And the same for reference two, it's exactly the same pointer as reference one. So
we're just adding a value new to do or array. So as you can see, all scalars that point to that
reference when edited will affect the original data structure. Now we looked at how we can get
a reference from existing data structure. Now let's see what happens if we are debugging these
values with data dumper using references. So here I have my array again, I backslash it,
as we did before to get reference in memory, and we print it out. And you're going to see that
instead of value one and value two being printed out with position war one, war two, we're actually
printing out a position war one, which holds this square brackets, having two elements inside of it,
which is string one, string two. So this indicates that we are working with array reference,
the same thing if we did with hash reference for center sign hash, save this, we're going to see
now instead of list items of E being, let's say war one pointing to war two, which is the value,
we're going to see the hash reference is include in curly brackets, a one and B two being our keys
and values. Now the same thing goes for the scalars. So you can say scalar and print that out.
And instead of seeing just a value 32, we're actually seeing this backslash, which indicates
we are working with array reference. Now it's worth knowing that you can construct reference
the same way how you can construct a hash or array. And the way you do it using the syntax
as it was printed out in data dumper. So I'm going to get rid of these values and I'm going to say my
hash ref. As I said before, we need to use curly brackets. And let's say add a key, hello, one
and rolled with value two. If we print this out, you're going to see this is a hash reference,
because we're using these curly braces instead of just parentheses. So we're working with hash
references. The same goes with arrays. So let's say I want to construct a array ref. And what
we saw before being printed out by data dumper was these square brackets. But there's the same
thing to construct array reference, we can say number 123, save this and print out the array ref,
look at a console. And here we go. So or square brackets 123 and closing square brackets.
Now how can you access items in your references? I'm going to go back and introduce the
hash ref with values of a well key pointing to value one and B pointing to value two.
There this up. What if I want to access, let's say in hash reference, only the key,
a, it's very similar as you would work with hashes. In hashes, you would say, hash, ref,
and then you use the curly braces to access element a. However, what you need to do when
you're working with references, you always need to dereference them. And one of the way how you
can dereference is by using this arrow notation. So you can access key a, save this, print it out.
And here we go, we can see that this is number one, if we wouldn't use the error syntax,
if I get rid of this, save it, try to rerun the script, it's going to say, hey, looks like you're
not using dereferencing syntax and you're accessing a hash somewhere, but I don't see this
being defined. Did you forget to define hash ref? Well, technically, no, we didn't forget to define
it. It's just we didn't want to access a hash. We wanted to access a hash reference, right?
So this is why we need to dereference using this arrow notation. The same goes for if I want to
access an element with array, within array. So I would say array ref, arrow syntax, square brackets,
as we saw before with arrays, and then we access by index. So if I wanted to access item with value
two, which is at the index position 01, I would type one here and I print this out and I see value
of two, because the same as with the race, array reference, items are indexed starting at position
zero. So zero, one, two. So if you're accessing index one, that means you're getting this element.
So what if you wanted to dereference your whole hash? You can do this in many ways. You could say
hash ref, arrow notation, percentage sign, nastrix, save this, we go to our console,
print it out. And here we go, we saw that same pattern of elements being key value printed out.
It's exactly the same for array ref. However, you would replace percentage sign with add symbol,
save this and go to the console, print it out and items 123. But remember, you read a reference or
get the reference in memory for data structures such as array hash or scalar by using backslash.
But if you want to convert back from array reference into the data structure, you would use
dereferencing not referencing syntax alternative dereferencing syntax would be using
the symbol before the dollar sign, save this, we rerun it and we see 123. And yet another way how
you can dereference is you can use at or what is the original data type curly brackets and ending
curly brackets. If we run this, it works. Now I mentioned previously, there's a thing about
references, specifically hash references and array references that you can create nasty structures.
So let's explore that. Let's say I have a key, a pointing to one B pointing to two. And what
if I wanted the key C that points to a another hash reference or hash structures, I'd say,
it's possible with hash references. So basically, what you're doing here is you're pointing
to a reference in memory, right? So you're not kind of merging your structure in, you can say,
a B is pointing to numbers and C is pointing to reference, they can say new equals one,
and new two equals number two. And if we try to print out the hash reference now,
the hash ref, save this printed out is going to say, here are my original values. And here's the
new C value we added, it's nested. And we can also introduce more nested values, such as deeply
can point to, let's say, array reference with values three, four and five, and save this,
I print out my hash. And here we go, or a key is now pointing to hash reference. And as I mentioned
before, this can be extremely useful when you need to store information in object pattern,
where keys are pointing to various types of data or information about the object you're working
with. The question is how, for example, we could access the value of C. So the key C in that hash
reference, the value of key new two. So what you could do is the same thing as we looked at to
dereferencing is you use arrow syntax, you say key C. And then you keep the referencing with
arrow syntax saying my new key two. If I print the cell, we have the value of two, which is under
the key new two, the same thing if I want to go deeper and say I actually want to access the deeply
key which holds array ref. So since we know it's array ref, what we need to do is we use the same
arrow notation and we access the value by index. Let's say two, which is going to be zero, one,
two, meaning it should be value of five. We save that, rerun it. Oh, and it looks like we have
syntax error. So we are accessing our hash ref, EC, which is here. And then we say there should be a
deeply E on the new two, which is actually pointing to value of two. What we need to do,
we actually need to access the deeply on the C structure. So if we change that, we rerun it.
And here we go, the value of five. And the same goes for arrays. So if we wanted to add nested
date structures, such as is my array ref, and I'm going to say first of all, it's just going to be
one. The second one can be a hash ref. And we're going to use this quote word syntax, which we're
going to spread in some strings into the second element, which is A, B and C. The third element
can be a hash ref, which says A with value one, B can be a nested hash ref, which has a key C that
points to hash ref that let's say has an element of hash ref again, with a key A pointing to a new
hash ref and so on and so on and so on. But you get it. The point being is that when you're working
with hash refs, you can nest the data structures as much as you want. If I try to print out this
structure, which is array ref, and I save this, here we go, we have first items, index position
one is value one, then has a hash ref with these three strings ABC, and then we have this nested
structure, which is a holding a hash ref value. And if we try to access this, and let's add a
value, for example, like find me, so it's going to hold two strings, fine and me. So let's look
into how we can access this structure is going to start with D referencing 012. So it should be at
index position two, we move forward, we want to access a key, which is B. So we type EP, we then
want to move deeper, access the key C. And the key C is actually pointing to a array ref, which
we can see here. And the first element is a hash ref. So we access the first element, and we know
this is a hash ref. And then we do reference that, and we that one has a key A, and if we save this
and print out, and here we go, it's gonna say find me. Now some of the very useful methods you can
use when you're working with these references is called ref. So let me just clear this up a bit.
And let's leave the hash ref only, you can use this function called ref takes a value in between
it. And you can add hash ref. And what's going to tell you is that you're currently working with a
hash ref, right? So ref tells you if the data structure you're working with is a reference,
in this case, yes, this is a hash ref, you could be passing in a raref, save this, and this is
anonymous array ref, we are not assigning assigning it to a scalar, but that's fine,
you can have anonymous references not belonging to any scalar. If you do this is going to say this
is a raref. The same of course goes for scalar ref, you can use the same methods on references
as you would use on your hashes or arrays. However, you always need to dereference your
structure. What I mean by that is for example, if you wanted to say keys on your hash ref, save this,
but the console is going to say you're starting to use keys on scalar, and that's forbidden. And
you can easily avoid that by just saying that we want to dereference it by some of the ways
we looked at before, for example, array notation for center sign and star. So we save this and we
run it. And here we go, we see keys bac, the exactly same thing would be for if you wanted to
call the values, you also need to dereference this for deleting such as hash ref equal let's
say we want to remove the key and we print out just the hash ref. Here it is, you have the key
c and only key a so b was deleted. The same would be for example, if an element exists,
but remember, you also need to dereference it with this arrow notation. So this is it for
this lecture, we looked at what our references, how you access and interact with references and
why they are extremely useful. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video, we will
learn what our subroutines in Perl and how we can use them. And we'll also look into Perl subroutine
signatures, also known as passing named subroutine arguments. Let's begin. First of all, a subroutine
is exactly the same thing as a function. It's a group of statements encapsulated in a single
function to perform a specific task. subroutines aka functions are extremely useful in any
programming language to encapsulate and reuse logic in your code. Typically, each subroutine
is written so that it accomplishes a very specific task. Let's look at how we can use subroutines.
To define a subroutine, you can use this keyword called sub, followed by a space and then your
function aka subroutine name. I'm going to call my function test and the logic that should be
executed by the subroutine is in these curly brackets. We have written our first function.
If I go to the console and try to run my script, which is which is Perl script.pl,
I'm going to see nothing. And this is because well, we have defined our subroutine and it is
a valid context. But there are two issues. First of all, it doesn't do anything. Let's change that.
Let's say I wanted to print. Hello, exclamation mark and backslash n for new align said this,
we have encapsulated the logic, but we're not calling it because the subroutine is not going
to be involved by default. If you want to invoke a subroutine, you can say test, which is our
subroutine name, followed by parentheses, and then semicolon. Now if we do this, rerun our script,
we're going to see hello. Now this is all great and all. But what if we wanted to accept some
parameters, and let's say that parameter was a name, and we want to say, Hello, someone, the way
how you can pass in arguments is by using a list context between these parentheses, where you have
defined your function name. So let's say I want to say john. So that's my first argument. But how can
we get this argument into our function itself, all the arguments in function is held in this special
variable. We haven't seen this before, but basically think of it as just an array. So all the
arguments being passed into your subroutine is going to be held into this magical array item at
index position zero is going to be john, this array is going to hold this string at position one,
technically, we should be able to say my name equals this is just normal array. But with this
special notation, how we can access items and array is we either use the dollar sign syntax,
followed by where brackets index position zero, this, we actually want to know interpolate the
name, we say this and go back to the console and rerun it. And here we see Hello john, it might be
clear if we say that this is my args. And I just copy all the values there. There's nothing really
special about this array apart from that it holds the values passed into the function. But here
we would be just copying these arguments. And then we could say, instead of this underscore,
we're just saying args, right? Because we learned about it before you access specific elements in
your array using dollar sign notation followed by where brackets, we save this rerun it. It works
as before. And just quickly show another alternative is that we could have used a shift function,
right? We could shift off items from our array, which is this special one holding all the elements.
And when we call shift, we get the first item in our list, and it should be a name. And here we go.
Hello john, this is also where references become very currently useful. Because if we wanted to
pass array, or a hash, we wouldn't be able to pass the content as a whole, right? Because
what would end up happening is that all the items from array and a hash would be spread
into this special array, we wouldn't be able to pass the whole structure. Let me show an example.
So let's say I have my array that holds quote word just add three strings, which is a, b and c.
Now how can I get a full structure without simply spreading the array elements into this special
function argument placeholder. Let's see what happens first, we just try to pass an array,
I'm going to remove this, I'm going to say now I want to print the dumper, and I'm going to print
all the arguments on the special array. And here I'm passing in array, I save this up. And here
we go. So basically, argument one was a argument b was a position to an argument c was, you know,
a position tree, you might want that, but most likely you didn't, maybe you just wanted to pass
in the whole data structure. And this is where you can use references. So as we looked at before,
you can use backslash to get a reference of your array. And now if we debug the special argument
placeholder, we're going to see that we passed in, oops, need to save my file as in a reference.
So we didn't copy all the values into the special array, we actually just said this is a reference
in memory to this array. Now what we could do, for example, in our function, we could move the print
statement out and say, I want to print out my array. But I want to do something in this function.
And let's say I wanted to push something on this array inside the function. And then let's see how
array changes. First of all, I want to get my array ref, which I passed in into the function. And I
can do this by shifting off the first argument of array. So I'm going to say my arg equals shift
special array, the argument should be the rare reference, I can use push arg, I need to dereference
it and say, this is a rare reference. And I want to say, from function, I'm going to push a new
string on this array inside my function after running it. And now I say print. And here we go.
Now I have four elements on my array. And we push this from function string here when we passed in
array reference, let's quickly look at variable scope. So we know that if we, for example, say,
my scalar equals Hello. And we would try to reuse this my scalar. And define a value of something
else, it would complain that, hey, looks like you have another scalar defined with the same name.
This does not count when you're using functions, because in functions, you are in a different
scope. So this curly bracket and this curly bracket indicates that this is scope of the
function. For example, let's get rid of the disk code and just say hello, mission mark, and this,
and we're going to color function, but we have no more array and we don't print anything.
If I call this, it looks all good. But if I'm going to say my scalar equals a save this,
go to the console printed out, don't complain, my variable scalar masks earlier declaration
in same scope. Now, if I move this scalar into here, and rerun the function, it's not going to
complain because, well, my scalar is defined inside this function, and the scalar bullet
is defined into our main file. First try to use the scalar, you might be wondering if it's going
to use the scalar which is defined outside the function, or is going to use the scalar which is
defined inside the function. And let's see around this. And you might have guessed it right, it
actually used scalar inside the function, because that's the local scope scalar. And it wouldn't
make sense if he had a variable with the same name, which is outside of function, we're redefining
it and we tried to print something and it's re referencing the value of scalar, which is
outside of function. Another thing to note is that you can define multiple subroutines. So I can say
test two, and I can say print Hello from test two. Now the thing is that you can call subroutines
from another subroutine. So let's replace this with Hello from test, save it up also to note the
order of how you define subroutines do not matter. For example, if you had a scalar with the value
Hello, and you try to print that before the definition of scalar, that will complain.
It's not the case with subroutines. These are actually initialized at compile time. So you can do
test. So you call the test subroutine from test two, which is defined before test. And let's
replace it with this two. And we run our code. And here we go, we see Hello from test and Hello from
test two, because we are calling test function, which is defined here inside the test two function,
which is called here. Now, a good thing to note is that I would advise you to always be explicit
when you are returning data in your function, it's good to define when you want to return
void context to return on death, or you actually want to return some value or calculated value,
and parallel functions are always going to return the last value you worked with. So you don't need
specifically have return statement. For example, if I say print, dumper, and here, I'm going to
call the test function. Let's say this function does one thing, which is defines variable a,
and it's number one, and it defines variable b, which is number two, that does a plus b, and
assign it to my C. So if we save this, and we run the logic, is going to say it's on death,
because we are explicitly returning on death. If you remove this return statement and call the
function is going to return three. So sometimes you don't actually want to return the last value,
which you're calculated from your function, but only do the calculations and do some printing,
or call another function. But the problem is that if you don't explicitly say that, hey,
I didn't want to return anything, then it might be confusing for the color. It's just a good
practice to say, either you want to return C explicitly, as such, or, or you don't want to
return anything, as we did initially by saying on death. Now, as promised, I did say before that
we're going to explore subroutine signatures. Subroutine signatures were introduced in pro
version 5.20. And it was classified as experimental until 5.34. However, the experimental warning was
removed at 5.36, which is the version currently I'm working with when making this video. As a pro
version, I'm going to say that this is 5.36. A very good timing to explore subroutines. Now,
how you can use subroutines with signatures is by using this program called use feature,
and then you import a specific feature you want to use. In this case, you can use quote word
notation that we looked at before. And since it's a single name, we can say signatures.
And that's it. We should not be able to use signatures in our pro code.
Let's remove this body syntax. And let's return back to the print. Hello,
exclamation mark, and the colon. Let's invoke our function as such. Let's remove the print.
And let's say we wanted to print out the name. So how we did it before we were passing in
an argument in this context, which we then got from this special array, which is at symbol underscore.
Now with signatures, we can actually define what arguments are going to receive in this function.
So if I say parentheses, and I am going to say that I want to receive a name,
if I run this is going to complain is going to say too few arguments for subroutine main package,
which is file and test. And it says that it got zero and expected one. And that's true, because
we're requesting one argument. And by default, if you use sub subroutine signatures, and you
define arguments as such, they are required. And since I'm not passing an argument here,
it complains, I can fix that by saying, john, again, the file, we run the script, and it works,
it says, Hello, john. So what if you didn't want to have mandatory arguments, you can use equals
notation and set the value to undefined, which means that the default we're not set is going
to be undefined, or you can just say, for example, a string, which is Bob. So if there is no argument
provided for this test function, then I want this argument, which is name, they have a value of Bob.
If I rerun this is going to say Hello, Bob. Now, one thing to note is that if you do want to have
an argument which is required, you must have it before the argument which is not required. So let's
say name is optional, but last name isn't. So I need to have the last name before the name. Otherwise,
you're going to get a warning that says your positioning of arguments is not correct. Let's
save this and rerun the file. We added a character that we don't want. So if I rerun the file now is
going to say too few arguments expected at least one argument. So because we expected last name,
we can set the last name to just last this rerun. rerun a script and say Hello, Bob, you can also
pass in named argument such as using hashes. I said these are my inputs. And I just want to do
one thing, which is print dumper to do its lowercase dumper backslash inputs, I'm going to print
actually the reference of this hash, because it gives us a better visual structure to debug what
they're passing here. If I do this, and let's say I have number one, which is going to hold a value
of one, and number two, which is going to hold a value of two, this rerun the script is going to
say that what we got here in the inputs, named argument inputs, which is hash, which we reference,
this is why we get this fine, nice structure is a key that points to value one, and key to which
points to value two. And this is very nice if you want to use named arguments, because it allows you
explicitly say what you want to pass in such as last name, first name, and so on. And the last
thing I want to show you is something that's called a Slurpee capture. And this is basically
array, which captures all the given arguments, and you don't need to name them. For example,
if I say at inputs, and I want to say that my first actual required input is name, but anything
that we pass in afterwards is not being required, or we don't want to set default values. But what
I can do, I can print out the name, what we're going to get. And I can also print out through
dumper the inputs we're going to get. So again, we're getting array, right? So we're capturing
all in array, what we're going to print out array reference by using this backslash, just for better
formatting. So now, if the first argument is set, let's say john, we print it out, is going to say
that, yes, the first item we got is john, but we got no further up elements. And this is because
we didn't pass anything extra. Now, if we want to pass more values 123, maybe let's drop in a hash
ref here as well with items A, B, and C. And if I save this, here we go. But the variable one
argument one is john, this is what we're printing out here for this dumper function and the variable
one for the second dumper print function holds value 123 and a hash ref which we passed in here.
And this is using square brackets because we are referencing or array inputs. Now this is it for
this video, we looked at what are subroutines, how to create and interact with them. We also explore
pro subroutine signatures and various ways how you can define them. I hope you found this video
useful and I'll see you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video,
we will explore variable scopes. In previous lecture, we saw how we can use subroutines.
And we also notice that if you define my and then the variable and then my variable inside
a subroutine, those names will not clash because there is a difference between scopes when you
would try to define a variable twice with the same name in the same scope. For example, in this file
you're currently looking at, you will get a warning these differences are called global scope
and local scope, we saw the my keyword, I can say my bar equals value one. However, there is a
another way how you can define your variables and that is by using or keyword. So we can say or
variable equals one, I can print it out by saying print, dumper, bar. Now if I go to console and type
curl, script.pl, I'm going to see variable one. On surface, this might not be visible why it might
be useful. So let's explore where this actually does come handy. And that is when we're trying
to use a script in another script, we will look into future lectures of how we can use and require
files and what is the difference between these two. But for now, let's just create a new file
through new file and call it script script to that bl. What we can do, we can go back to our script
file and let's copy everything what we see here. On my Mac, I'm using command C, I'm going to go
into script to paste that all in. I'm going to print out and hello from script to save it up,
go to my script original script one. And I'm going to use this special keyword, which is called
require. And I'm going to require my script to file since my script to file is currently next to
my script.pl, I can use dot notation forward slash, which says use the relative path to this folder
and script to that bl. And it's semicolon. I'm going to remove these values for now,
I'm going to save script that bl, and go back to the console, I'm going to run the script that bl,
which is real, that bl, what I'm going to see is hello from script two. So that means that
when we require this file, the script to, we actually got the print statement involved.
But what if, for example, we had some variables we wanted to use in our script to let's say these
variables called my script to underscore war equals secret. So if I save this, and I'm actually
going to comment out this Hello from script to go back to script one, and I will try to do print
script to underscore war, save this, go to the console, going to say bubble symbol script to
war requires explicit package name, it hasn't been declared. But it's strange because we are
acquiring script to and there is a variable script to underscore war. Why is it complaining? Well,
again, it's due to the scope. So by default, if you use my keyword, the scope is currently to this
file, this variable is not exposed to the script.pl file. Now if we wanted to expose this variable to
script two, this is where the or keyword comes into play. You can change my to or go back to
script.pl, try to rerun. However, as you can see, it's still not working. So another thing we need
to do is we need to explicitly define that we want to pull in this variable from script to file.
Otherwise, we're going to get this warning. And this is because of the progress, you need to be
explicitly requiring this variable. So there is no confusion whatsoever. And you can do this by
saying or brackets, or a list of variables we might want to define. And I'm going to say I want
my script to underscore war, save it, go back to the console, try to run the pro script file again.
And it works. What we got here is we said print script to war, which holds a string called
secret. And this is in script to where we actually could access the variable to by explicitly saying
we want to use globally scoped variable called script to war. And we want to pull this into
this script and print it out from this file. Now in last lecture, what we saw was this use feature
and subroutines. But we can use another feature which is called state. And state is a special
keyword used before your variables, which tells your script that this variable should be initialized
once and only once in the memory through all the execution of script. What do I mean by that? Well,
if we try to introduce a subroutine, let's say test and curly brackets, and let's say I want to say
my bar, which is a scalar equals one, and I'm going to print out bar plus one and concatenate
it with new line. So if I call this function test, save it, go to the console, I'm going to see
do a little bit nudge there. So let's maybe add a string before that,
concatenate that and go back to the console. Of course, because now we need to wrap it in brackets
to explicitly define that we have a string context, we want to concatenate with the context,
we were actually adding numbers and then concatenate that context with a new line.
So you can use parentheses to kind of isolate your context. If we go to console, try to print it
again, we can see greater than and two. And what if we want to recall this function many times,
we run it again, you can say 2222. And this is because every single time we're using my
in a code block, this variable is initialized each time we call the test function. But what if we
didn't want to do that? What if we actually wanted to initialize this variable only once and keep
track of this value every time we execute this function? Well, we can use the keyword state.
So if I replace my with state, save the file, go to the console and rerun or test functions,
which are being called five times, and we actually need to change things up. If you think about it,
the value didn't change because we are saying variable equals one and that was initialized once,
but we are adding variable plus one and not increasing it. We're just adding one to variable
and then printing it out. It's not actually setting that variable to higher number. So how
we can increase that number is by removing this and saying variable concatenated. And here we want
to do var plus equals one, we save this script. So now we're going to see 2345. And just to verify
that it actually works as expected, if I change state to my save it, you run it, you need to say
222. As I mentioned before, using my decoration, every time we enter this code block, it sets it
to one, increments it by one and then prints it out using state. If I change it back, we initialize
it once to number one, and we keep incrementing this variable, which is defined once in a memory.
And if I rerun this again, we can say 23456. Now where can this be useful? You might find yourself
in scenarios where you're creating maps, lookup maps of some keys, values, which are never going
to change in your program, such as translations or special use case mappings. In this case, you don't
really want to initialize your map every single time. What I mean by this, you could say state
map equals a one, B equals two, and C equals three. And if I wanted to simply print what's in the map
by accessing what was passed into arguments, so we're going to use the dollar sign underscore,
remember, because all the arguments are in at underscore, and to access a single element,
we could use dollar sign underscore, and then square brackets, which is the first argument. So
if we just wanted to print out the first argument from this map, we can use state because this is
never going to change, a is going to be pointing to one, c is going to always be pointing to three
in this scenario. And if we remove this and add, let's say a to print out, yes, looks like we're
actually saying that this is a hash using array ref syntax. So we should be using braces,
let me move this into here. Set up remove this curly brackets and rerun it forgot the semicolon.
And this is good. It's always good to read your errors. In this case, I did not add a semicolon
on the line 19. It says that there was an error, we couldn't print it. And this is because there
was no semicolon added on line 17. It actually gives you a suggestion versus a syntax error
on line 20 near early bracket, which refers back to previous error, the or map wasn't defined while
it was defined, but it wasn't defined properly. If we save it, the vector console rerun it,
we can see number one. So this is it for this video, we looked at different scopes and how
you would apply them in practice, we saw scenarios where you might want to use or keyword when
required multiple scripts, or you might consider using state keyword to initialize your data once
and only once in memory for execution of your script lifetime. I hope you found this video
useful, and I'll see you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video,
we will explore how we can handle exceptions in Perl. Specifically, we will look into how we can
throw exceptions and how to safely capture exceptions. In general, exceptions happen all
the time. Unfortunately, even in production, for example, if you try to access a database that is
not available, or you try to read write to a file that does not exist, or read them all form JSON,
so on and so on, if such exceptions happen, we might want to handle them gracefully and recover
in the code without breaking the functionality of our script. So let's see how we can handle
exceptions in Perl. The thrown exception, you can use the keyword called died. Now whenever this is
invoked, an exception is going to be thrown and our script is not going to execute the code which is
followed after the die statement. For example, if I add a print, hello, call the new line, save this,
print our script. I'm going to see that our script died at line seven, and nothing was printed out
because our print statement followed after die, exception, and execution of our code did not
continue after line seven. If I would move this line before die statement, save this, rerun our
script file, we're going to print hello, and then it's going to die at line eight. It's also worth
noting that you control named exceptions, such as die cannot go on. If we save this, rerun our
script file, we're going to see hello printed and then cannot go on at line eight. Now this is how
you control exceptions in Perl. Now the question is how you can handle them. Now to handle exceptions
in Perl, you can use this keyword called evil, followed by opening and closing curly brackets,
and ending with semicolon. If we move this die block inside evil, and move this print block after
the evil, run our code, we're going to see that our script executed as we expected. So hello was
printed to the terminal. And we do not see that the execution of the script stopped. However,
what I said before, regards to the code not executing after exception is thrown, still
applies inside evil block to demonstrate, let's introduce a new variable, which is my test and
assign world as a value. And then we're going to interpolate this into this print statement by
saying hello, variable test, run this, it prints hello world as expected, because we defined our
variable before evil, and then we print or hello, and this variable interpolated. However, if I
will try to reassign a value, let's say test equals Bob, save this, go to the terminal,
and run our script is going to say hello world. And why is that? Well, we did declare our variable
test, and we assign a string world, then we try to assign a string Bob to our test variable and
print it out again. However, inside our evil block, we also threw an exception. And once this
exception was thrown, we never got around assigning the value of Bob to our test variable. Now, how
can we know when an exception was thrown? Well, pro has a special keyword for this. And whenever
exception occurs, and it's being captured in evil block, the value of that exception is going to be
assigned in dollar sign at symbol. So currently, this variable holds the name of our exception,
you can use this variable, for example, to print out if an exception was thrown. So if I move this,
into our print statement, those semicolon, paste it here, save our script file and run it again,
we're going to see the hello world semicolon, and then cannot go on at script line 10. Now,
this can be useful if you want to compare if a value was set in this special variable,
know if you want to execute a specific code. For example, if you would comment out die statement,
go to the terminal printed out again is going to say hello Bob. So currently or dollar sign at
variable was no exception, or no exception was thrown. We're going to see later on our lectures
how to use logical statements to compare if values are set, and you can execute different
type of logic based on if there is or isn't a value in this special variable. Alternatively,
if you just want to say that something did not happen according to the plan, but you don't want
to stop the execution of your script, you can use a keyword called warn. And this warn is going to
print to the standard error output. If I say warn, something is not right. Save this, run our script,
oops, and looks like we left the test variable here. So let's remove that. Maybe also let's remove
this global variable and just print Hello, rerun our script, we're going to see something is not
quite right, which is what we warned about online six, but our script actually got her on line eight
of printing Hello. So warn is something that prints to the standard error outputs, but it does not
stop the execution of your script. And it's very handy if you want to notify when things go wrong,
but it's not on a level that it might break your script logic. So you're happy to proceed to note,
this is a basic out of the box approach and how to handle exceptions in pro there is a much better
way to throw and capture named exceptions that we will look into the future lecture. So this is it
for this video. We looked at how we control and handle exceptions in pearls out of the box
solution. I hope you found this video useful and I'll see you at the next one.
Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. This video we will explore logical operators in pro.
We already looked at operators used for addition and subtraction of numbers. We also looked at
into how we can concatenate strings. Now there are many more operators you can use to compare
if your numbers are equal, or if your strings are equal, or number is greater or less, or maybe
they're equal. Let's explore this concept of logical operators. Before we do that, I do want
to introduce you to a ternary statement. And a ternary statement is a block, which takes an
expression followed by a question mark, and then it returns a result, which is at position one,
if it's true, followed by colon, and another expression if it's false. For example, if I
want to say print something which is a ternary expression, like one, which evaluates truthy,
then I want to print yes. Otherwise, if it's not true, we use colon as mentioned before.
And we're going to say no. If I go to the console, say pro script.pl is going to say yes, because
this is expression which needs to evaluate to true for us to print yes. And if it wouldn't
be true, it would print no in pro all the truthy values are one, or a string cheese of length,
at least one references are truthy, because they're going to point to memory, even anonymous
references, if you're not assigned to scalars, or a negative number, nor a false value is anything
which is for example, zero undefined or empty string. So if I want to say print is on depth
truthy, rerun the script is going to say no, it's not truthy. Same goes for example, if I want to say
is empty string truthy? No, it's not. No, one got your pearl is that a string which holds a
value of zero is actually a falsey, you would expect that if it's a string, it holds a number
which is zero. So technically, it's not a full length zero, which I mentioned before, but there
is an exception. If you say number one, this is truthy, and the final falsey value is zero.
So if you run this is going to say no, now let's try to do some comparisons with numbers. But
before we move forward, I'd like to introduce you to a feature feature, which is called say,
and say is just a handy function, which automatically adds a new line at the end
of whatever we're printing. I can say something, which is the same statement. And I rerun this
is going to print no to our console. But as you can see, it adds a new line. So it's kind of
handier than using print and then manually appended a new line. And especially cases where
you're debugging things, you might want to consider just using the save function, which
automatically does this appending of new line. So now let's start with comparing numbers. Let's say
I want to check if one equals to zero. And how you can do that is by using this double equals mark
is going to compare if one equals zero, and if it is going to print yes, and if it's not,
then it's going to print no, I've tried to print this I'm getting now because well, one is not
equal to zero, and also reverse this and say is one not equal to zero, which is going to print
yes, one is not equal to zero, you can also compare if one is greater than zero, which should give you
yes, if one is greater than zero, and the opposite is one less than zero, which is going to give you
no, one is not less than zero, you can also combine less than and greater operators using
the less than or greater operator, followed by equals, you can see that is one less than or equal
to zero if you try to print it out, no, and is one greater or equal to zero is going to say yes,
because one is greater or equal to zero, the same thing would be, if I would say is zero greater or
equal to zero, well, zero is not greater than zero, but it is equal to zero. So this is going to print
yes. Now there's also this special operator called three way comparison, which is basically going to
return you minus one, zero, or one, depending of if the values you're comparing are less than equal
or greater. This is very useful when you want to use it in functions like sorting or mapping things,
but probably you wouldn't use it on daily basis that often. However, let's take a look at this
operator. So if I say something, and I'm going to say is one, then we use this freeway comparison
operator, also known as spaceship operator, because it goes like less than equals greater than one.
And that's all I want to print. I just want to print the result of this. And I want to comment
out the previous line, it's comparing if one equals one, which is zero, we're getting zero, because
value on our left hand side is equal to the value to the right hand side. Now if I set the value on
right hand side to zero, which is less than one, and I print this out, give it back to one, but
it's not one what we're printing out here, I could change this to 20, print it out. And I'm going to
say still one, because it's a three way comparison, one zero minus one. And now if I change the zero
to 40, which is actually bigger than 20, we're going to get minus one. So you're going to get one
if the value on your left hand side is larger than the value on your right hand side, zero,
if both values are equal or minus one, if the value on your right hand side is larger than the
value on your left hand side. Now let's look at strings. Strings are very similar. We have the
same comparison logic, which you can say, for example, is a equal or greater to b. However,
you need to use these special words instead of less than equals than or greater than operators,
and they could be violent comparison operators for strings are called equal the checks is a equal to
b. And that's a no, because a is not equal to b, then there's also not equal is a not equal to b,
which is yes, a is not equal to b. Now the next thing is lt for less than. And it's yes, because
a is less than b in alphabetical order, I could swap this around and say is b less than a,
then we know because he follows after a, and there's also greater than which is gt. And this
prints out yes, because is b greater than a, which is yes, because b follows after a. And if I swap
this around, I would get no, you also get equivalent operators for less than or equals. So you can use
le or less than or equals. So is b less than or equals to a, which is no, it's neither equal or
less than. But if I changed a to b, is going to give that give us yes, because b equals b. And if
I change this to c, I'm also going to get yes, because is b less than c? Yes, it is less than,
but it's not equals. However, it passed the first condition. So we get yes. And as you have guessed,
we also have greater or equal. So you can use g e for greater equals. Now the question is b
greater than or equal to c? No. However, is c greater than or equal to c, which is yes,
because c equals c. So we get yes, we can also check this with d. So is d greater than or equal
to c? Yes, yes, it is, because d comes after c. Now, another useful thing you can do in pro is
you can change your expressions, which is two or more expressions has to be true in order to print
or positive scenario, which is the yes string, or you can say one or the other scenario has to be
true in order to print or positive scenario. Let's look at simple example, we could say one
is bigger than zero. And we should use two amper signs to is bigger than one. If you run this,
we're going to see yes printed to a terminal. And this is because our left hand side expression
was true. And our right hand side expression was true. And that means we printed out the yes
string. However, if I would change one to three, and try to run the script again is going to print
no. And this is because or left hand side still evaluates to true. However, or right hand side
now evaluates to false. And we're indicating with two amper signs that both of these expressions
have to be true in order to go into the positive scenario, which is printing out the yes keyword.
Now, if you only cared about one or the other expression being true, you can use these two
pipes, which literally mean or another saying, if the left hand side condition is true, or the right
hand side condition is true, then print out yes, I run this is going to print yes. And what pro does
it goes in this left hand side, it evaluates if it's truthy. And if it is truthy, it's not going
to even check their next expressions, because we know already that our scenario passes, though we
can print out the yes string. And you can change these expressions even further by using brackets,
such as I could say if one is larger than zero, and I encapsulate these parentheses.
And let's say if two is bigger than three, or one is bigger than zero, save this is going to print
yes, if we bisect this, we're going to see that one is bigger than zero, and one or the other
condition encapsulated after two amper signs is true, which in this case, who is not larger than
three, however, one is larger than zero, we're going to print yes string, if we would change this
to the amper signs, it basically means that all the conditions have to be truthy. If we rerun the
script, we're going to see no, because now our second condition doesn't pass. And that means
there is no point to evaluate the right hand side expression, because we know our expressions did not
pass all the necessary conditions. And you can use this logic even with comparing strings,
as we saw before, we looked at less than equals than or greater or equals than and so on. It's
not just the numbers. Let's quickly look at assignment operators and some shortcuts. You
already know that we can initialize new variable, let's say a num that holds a value of 20 using
equal sign. And let's try to say this num, our console, if you save it, run it, we get print 20.
And now what if we wanted to add a number, we saw that we can add something to a number by saying
num equals num plus five, so we can get 25. But you can use a shortcut and the shortcut is
plus equal five. And if we run this, we can see 25 again. So basically what this does, it says
add five to the same variable we're currently working with, so add plus five to this num
variable, it's just a neat way to do additions, instead of writing the full num plus five, and
so on. And as you imagine, you can also use minus equals, we print this one out, we get 15. And we
can use all the mathematical operators. For example, if we want to use multiplication, we can use
Asterix, we print this out, we get 100, or we can use division. And we're going to get four,
because we are dividing self with five, which is four, so we set the number to four, and so on,
we have very similar shortcut to strings as well. So if I say my string for str equals hello,
you append something to string, you could say string equals string dot notation,
base, world exclamation mark. So if we say this one out,
you can see hello world, if we want to quickly append something that we can say dot equals,
which is going to give us hello world. Now there's another interesting operator,
which is called repetition operator, and it allows you to repeat a string multiple times,
and you repeat it by writing x very similar to multiplication, as you write it on paper,
but in pro x is to multiply a string. So let's say if we wanted to multiply h six times, we can use
h character x for multiplication sticks, and then we print out the string is going to print h h h.
And if we just add a space to make it more clearer, we're going to print out h space, h space,
and so on and so on. You can also use operators to increment or decrement things. For example, my
num, which equals 10. And we can say num plus plus, and say the num, we print this out,
we can see that num is 11. Or we can decrement num by saying num minus minus equals nine. So
it might not seem that it's quite useful at this point, but it does become useful in loops and
statements where we calculate things. And we will look into that in our next lecture. Just a final
side note is that these are not all the available logical operators in Pro. However, these are
definitely the ones you will find yourself using the most. And this is it for this video. We looked
at different operators in Pro, how you put them in practice in strings, numbers, and when you're
trying to compare them between each other. I hope you found this video useful, and I'll see you at
the next one. In this video, we will explore conditional statements in Pro. So what is a
conditional statement conditional statement is a block of code that will be executed if one or
more expressions at the beginning of the conditional block evaluates true. Furthermore,
conditional statements can be extended with additional cases to execute different logic
based on given expressions. This all might sound confusing. But don't worry, let's look at some
basic examples to make it easier to understand. We already explored one of the conditional
statements in our previous lectures. And that conditional statement is called turn rate
statement. This way you give expression followed by a question mark and a block of logic you want
to execute if the expression is true. Otherwise, followed by colon, block of logic you want to
execute if it's false. Just repeat it again with the example we could say aka printer console,
if two is larger than one, then we want to print out hello. Otherwise, we want to print out world.
If we save this, run our code. Oops, we need that symbol at the end of this. Run our code again,
we're going to see hello, printed in our console. This is because two is larger than one, and we
print it out. Hello. Now we could execute the opposite case if we would reverse this conditional
check, which would evaluate to false. For example, we could say is one larger than one, run our code
with proscript.pl. And we're going to see world printed out to our console. This is because one
is not larger than one, one is equal to one. Now this is a basic example. What if we wanted to
execute more logic, not just printing out a single string? Well, we could use a conditional statement
by saying if or logic bracket, we have to provide expression that evaluates to true or by opening
and curly braces. And let's add some code there. Let's say I want to print out hello. And I also
want to print out world. Now let's add expression in our if statement and say if two is larger than
one, save the file, run the code proscript.pl, we're going to see two things printed out. We could
also do more expressions such as we could define a variable saying my var equals one, and then we
could print it out by saying my var, then interpolate that variable into a string, save it, run the code
again, we're going to see hello, world and my var, which holds the value one, you can add a lot of
logic and other expressions in the if block that needs to be executed with a condition beginning
at the if block evaluates to true. Now what happens, for example, if I say if one is larger than one,
let's save this, run our code, we're going to see nothing printed to our console. This is because
one is not larger than one. So this block of code does not execute, we're not seeing anything in the
console. In cases where our expression didn't evaluate to true, we could use another keyword
called else, followed by opening and curly brackets. And then we could print something like
this is else part at semicolon, save this rerun our script, we're going to see this is else part
printed in our console, you could actually extend this conditional statements even further. For
example, I could say if my variable which is test equals one, and then I could compare if test is
larger than one and use a keyword which is else if written with ELS if so you don't write the full
else word followed again by opening and closing brackets. And let's say if test equals one with
two equal signs, and add curly brackets, and then we could say something like middle part,
save our code, go to the console, run the script, and we're going to see middle printed out in our
terminal, you can add as many as ELS if blocks as you want. However, do note that if you have
else blocks that meet two different conditions that evaluate to true, let's say I have first
else if that evaluates to true and a second else if but if I wanted to print out middle two,
go to console, run the script, is just going to print the middle part. So the key point to
remember here is that these blocks of code execute in sequential order. And once a truthy
condition is met, the execution of your code stops. So this first part did not evaluate to true,
but the second part then since it's evaluated to true, the rest of the code did not run. Now
another keyword you could use is unless and unless works exactly like if but opposite. So meaning if
your condition evaluates to false, then your code is going to be run. For example, if I type unless
opening and closing parentheses, say if test is larger than two, say, this is a negative case,
save this, run our script again, and the same as with if blocks, you could extend it further with
else if and put your conditions here and end it with else. However, do note that unless can be
quite tricky to understand, especially if you want to add multiple conditions, from my experience,
you really need to stop and think what this keyword is actually meaning because it basically
says if not true, and if you have many conditions in that unless block, it's just going to get very,
very confusing. However, do know that you can use unless in conditional assignments, which becomes
extremely useful and much more easier to read than saying if not conditioned. Let's see what I mean
by that. For example, if I want to print out this test variable by saying bar test. And let's say I
wanted to change the test value to two if two is larger than one. If you run this, we're going to
see bar equals two printed to our console because we define a variable with a value of one and then
we assign value to if this expression is true. We could also say assign a value of two unless three
is larger than two. If we save this from the code, we're going to see bar equals one. This is because
we're saying our variable equals to one. And then we're saying assign value of two to our variable
unless three is larger than two. Well, three is not larger than two. And that means two is never
assigned to this variable. And this is one of my favorite features in pro because you don't need to
use ternary expressions to reassign values. If you come from different programming languages,
you might know that you have to use ternary expressions such as test equals two, and then
you need to provide your conditions such as three is larger than two if yes, then value equals two,
otherwise value equals one. If we print this, then we see that the value of two was assigned
because three is larger than two in pro you can say best equals three if two is larger than one,
we print this out again, here we go best now holds a value of three. This is it for this video.
Hopefully the conditional statements and using conditional statements in assignment context are
much clearer now and you feel more comfortable using them in practice. I hope you found this
video useful and I'll see you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this
video, we will explore loops in pro. So what is a loop? Well, loop is a very similar to the
conditional statement principle we looked at before. However, instead of running the code once
in a conditional statement, the code in the loop will be executed multiple times while the expression
in the beginning of the loop evaluates to true. Let's look at different loops in pro and some
examples on how to use them. And the first loop we're going to look at is the while loop, you
construct your while loop by typing while opening and closing parentheses, and then opening and
closing early brackets. As you might have guessed, you put your expression inside the parentheses as
with the conditional statement. Now here you could say something like while two is larger than one,
we want to print hello world. If I run this now, this is actually going to cause infinite loop
because this file condition is always going to pass meaning is going to print hello world all
the time to the console. Let's add a condition which is going to tell us when the while loop
should stop running. For example, let's introduce a variable as before test equals one. And here we
could say while test is less than 10. We want to print out hello world. And let's add the test
variable here as well. I save this on the script looks like we're actually causing infinite loop.
And the reason is because we are never actually incrementing the test variable, which is causing
the while loop to run indefinitely. So what we could do, as we saw before, we could use this
post increment with plus plus. So meaning every single time we're going to hit the while loop,
we're going to print hello world and our variable test. And then we're going to increment the test
variable by one. And this is going to run while test is less than 10. If we save this, run our
code again, we're going to see hello world and our variable value printed afterwards. So this runs
nine times while the test is less than 10. And you can add different kinds of expressions, which
need to evaluate the true while some sort of condition is not met. And once your condition
is met, you can exit the while loop. In this case, we're using a test variable, which are
incrementing while it's less than 10. But your case can be different. Now another loop we could
use is the for loop. And it's very similar to while loop, meaning we have to give it a condition
that needs to evaluate for the loop to run knows when to exit. However, the difference is here,
we provide init variable followed by the expression that needs to evaluate the true or the loop to
run. And then we need to provide a handle of how or initial variable should be incremented or
decremented for expression to keep running. Let's look at some examples such as say, hello,
a test variable and save this. And now let's replace the blocks that we need to initialize
in order for for loop to run, or we could say my test starting value equals zero.
And the expression could be while test is less than 10. And the handle could be test plus plus.
So we're initializing a test variable to zero, we're running the loop while the test variable
is less than 10. And afterwards, we're incrementing this variable by one, we save this,
run our script, we're going to see value of zero printed up to the nine. And you can of course
averse this by objecting a value, then checking while the value is less than x or similar cases.
Now another loop in pro we're going to look at is called for each loop. And for each loop basically
goes through every single element in the given list. And once it reaches the last element is
going to stop the execution. For example, we could say for each my item, and that we could provide a
list. And very similar to previous cases, we're going to say, hello, and we're going to print out
item, save this. And another thing we need to do, we need to define the list. So I'm going to say
that my list is going to hold values from one to 10. And we saw in our previous lecture is that
what this basically does is do that symbols is going to construct a list by populating the items
from one till 10. So it's going to go 12345678910. If I save this, run our script, I'm going to see
an items printed to the console. So what the for each loop did, it went through every single item,
which we declared in local scope inside the list, and it printed out in the loop. Now for the
warning here, if you're coming from other programming languages, you might expect that
when you're iterating through a list, and you're modifying item in place is going to modify a copy
of an item in that list. And well, this is not the case, when you're modifying an item in a loop,
it's actually going to modify the item in the given list. So what I mean by that is, for example,
if he said for each my item, I could say item equals item plus one, which could also be written
as plus equals one. If we print this out, we're going to see 2, 3, 4, 10, 11, because now every
single item is incremented by one. However, if we exit the for each loop, and we print out by a
dumper, or list by referencing it, because it's going to give us a nicer structure, if you rerun
the script, or go to the semicolon, if you rerun our script again, we're going to see that here we
go, we printed out 2, 3, 4, 5, 7, and so on, because we incremented an item in the loop. However,
afterwards, once we printed our list, all the items on our list actually changed. So in our
original list, we had items from one till 10, then we incremented that item by one inside the loop,
and this changed the items in place in the list we were working with. But just a word of warning,
whenever you're working with loops, and you're modifying values, just remember that you're
modifying the values in the list. Another useful thing you can do with the loops, you can miss them,
for example, if we introduce a new list, let's call it nested, and we're going to add only two
items here, it's going to be one and two, let's go inside our for each loop, let's remove the
submission. And now let's go through our nested loop items, I'm going to say for each, my nested
item, the list of nested items, I'm going to print something with backslash t or tab,
so that we can better see it in a console, I'm going to say nested, and I'm going to print out
the nested item, I save this, go to the terminal, run the script, let's remove this dumper. So we
have a better visibility, let's rerun our script, we're going to see now is that we have hello one,
and afterwards, we have nested printed out, hello two, and nested one and two. So what happens here
is that we go through each item in the list, starting with one. And in every iteration,
we're running an inner loop. And that inner loop goes through all the items in this array called
nested. So we hit the first item, then we go through one to that we can see in the terminal here,
then we go to the second item, which is in the main loop, and we go through all the items which
are in the inner loop, so on and so on. And you can nest many loops as you want. Just do be careful
because the behavior can become quite unpredictable. If you have many nested loops will become very
hard to follow the logic very quickly. You might find yourself in scenarios where you actually
want to exit a loop, or you maybe want to skip to the next item. And for this pro has some couple
of keywords to control your loops, these keywords are next, last, redo and go to let's take a look
at the next keyword. So for example, you can introduce something like next, if our item equals
two. So if we save this, we run our script. And if you look at the output, what we're going to see
is that we printed out the main loop and the nested loop statements. However, when we went
to the second loop item, which holds a value of two, we did print out the hello item from the
main loop. However, we did not print items in a nested loop. And this is because we used the next
keyword and the control statement of if as we saw in previous lectures that says go to the next
iteration if the current item we're iterating has a value of two, but execution which followed
afterwards never happens. You can also use a keyword such as last as the name implies you
might figure out that this keyword simply ends the loop by saying that this is the last iteration we
want to execute. If we save this, go to our terminal was cleared up, we run our code, we're
going to see that we went through the first item and also through the nested loop. However, once
they hit the second item, we printed out the first statement because it's before the last keyword,
but we never get around the for each inner loop. And this is because we said that we want this to
be the last iteration if the value of the item equals two, we can also use a keyword redo. And
again, as the name implies, it's going to redo the same loop if the item value matches of what
we're looking for. If I clear the console, we run the script with pearl script.pl. Oh, this is
actually going to result in infinite loop and the infinite loop accord because we printed out the
first item that had earlier one, then we went to the next item, which has a value of two, and we
say redo this loop if value equals two. Now since we're redoing this loop, and the value is always
two, this causes infinite loop. Now what we could do here, we could increment item by one, save this,
rerun our script. And what we're going to observe here is that we actually printed one,
then we incremented item by plus one. And that means it now holds a value of two. So we read
the loop, however, the value now is three, meaning this statement executed, it read the loop, since
the value now is four, we actually never print out the nested loop. So we skip this part by
incrementing item by one, redoing the loop with incremented value and moving to the next item in
the list. Now there's also this keyword go to for this to be executed, we will need to talk about
named loops. And basically what named loops are, you can add this keyword before your loop in
uppercase, such as loop one, followed by column, and then we can say loop two. Now what we could
do here, instead of printing Hello, actually, let's leave the printing of Hello. But before
this printing of the outer loop, let's add the statement that's going to say go to loop two,
if item equals one, we save this, rerun our code. And let's observe the results. What we're going
to see now is that we do have Hello to printed out to the console and the nested loop afterwards.
However, in this scenario, which is the first one where the value is one in the main loop,
we don't have anything printed that says Hello one. And this is because we are saying if the
item value in the first iteration equals one, or well in any iteration, or that matter, we want to
stop the execution, which is in between the go to statement and the loop, which you're saying go to
just execute the next loop. And then loops are quite handy when you're using nested loops,
you can apply these names or keywords as next or last, if you want to be specific, which exactly
loop you're referring to. So what I mean by that is if we remove this part, let's leave the say
Hello item, which is in our main loop, and let's go to the inner loop. And after printing nested,
I'm going to say last loop one, if item equals one, we save this, rerun our code,
we're going to see Hello one printed, then nested one printed. And that's it. And this is because
again, we went through the main loop, we printed item one here, then we're going to second loop,
we print the first item in the nested loop, but then we say last loop, which is named one and
refers to the outer loop if the item value is one is the first item in the list has a value one,
and that's it, we're done with execution. So named loops are quite handy if you want the granular
control of the loop execution when you have nested loops. This is it for this video, we looked at
loops in Perl and how you can apply them in practice. I hope you found this video useful,
and I'll see you at the next one. Hi there, and welcome to this lecture. In this video,
we will explore what are regular expressions also known as regexes, and how to use them in Pro. In
natural, a regular expression is a string of characters and symbols that defines a pattern
you want to match against your string value, you might have heard the pro is very powerful when
it comes to using regular expressions. And that is quite true. It is extremely easy to use regexes
in Pro. And there are various tools baked into Pro to match and modify your data using regular
expressions. Let's look at some examples of using regexes in Pro. We'll be using conditional statement
to see if our regex is true. So we can do if something is true, then let's say again,
print something to the console, which is going to be matches with exclamation mark. Now how you can
match a regex by giving a variable such as test, then equal sign, followed by tilde and two
forward leaning slashes. And then you could add your character matching such as dog. If I would
define my variable and say, best equals cat. Let's also introduce else expression. And let's say,
does not match, save this runner script, we're going to see that this does not match. And it
makes sense because we're testing if this variable called test matches a pattern, which is dog. Now,
if we try to match something like dog, rerun our script, we're going to see, yes, it matches. And
you can add other strings such as at and mouse. And in between there, we can have dog. And it's
going to say matches because the regex looks at all of the string and looks for this particular
pattern of dog inside that string. It's all string contains cat, dog, mouse, and it has dog between
it matches. So it prints out matches. Now, what if you actually wanted to test for something like,
is there a forward leaning slash inside the regex? And if we run our pro script now is going to say,
oof, there is a syntax error. And that makes sense because our regex pattern is defined by
two forward leaning slashes. So by adding the third slash, it's invalid syntax. So one of the
alternatives is to use backslash. And backslash is basically escaping these special characters,
and they're going to be understood literal characters. So here, we're looking for literal
or leaning slash in our string. If you rerun this again, this does not match because our
string does not have a forward leaning slash. But if we add that here after dog, save this,
I run our script again, it matches alternative is you can use this M modifier. And what M modifier
allows you to do is change the wrapping syntax of your pattern. So we can use something like early
brackets instead of forward leaning slashes to build our pattern. If we rerun this again,
it says it matches. And without the M modifier, this becomes invalid syntax. And it's already
seen by the syntax highlighter by the code editor. If we rerun, it basically says something is not
right with your code. You can also add some modifiers. So first, if we fix this, and dog
and forward leaning slash, we rerun this, this is fine. So you could actually try to match something
at the beginning of the string and the end of the string by using this roof character,
and then dollar sign. So this means that your string, the pattern you're looking for has to be
exactly do g forward slash from the beginning and the end of the string. And now if we rerun this,
we're going to see does not match because there's a cat and a mouse wrapping or pattern we're
looking for. If you remove the cat part, and we remove the mouse part, save this rerun or script,
we're going to see that it matches. You can also use special rejects keywords such as to look for
a character or look for a number or something that is not a character or not a number. And you can
do this by going backwards, leaning slash. And for a any word character, you could say W. And here,
if we amend the string to say dogs, rerun our script, we're going to see that it matches,
because now we're looking for anything that is do g followed by a character. So this extra character
is s now to match something that is not a character, you can use capital W. And I'm going
to add a resource link, which is going to tell you what exactly is considered and is not considered
a word character. Let's add a hyphen character and rerun our script, we're going to see that this
matches because hyphen is not considered a word character, you could also use backslash D and
backslash D is a number. Let's say if you're matching against dog one, save this from the
script, it's going to say matches because we're looking at something that is beginning to the end
containing dog followed by number. So since one is a number, and this matches. So what if we added
another number, save this rerun or script is going to say it does not match, because here we are
looking for exactly one number after the drink dog, but we could do something like plus. So that
means we're looking for one or more number after the dog, we can add more numbers, save this,
rerun our script, and it's going to say matches, we could also use star instead of plus, if we run
this is going to say matches. Now what star does it basically says there can or cannot be a number
and we don't really care. So we can match against dog exactly, or there could be numbers, which is
these. And if we save this rerun, it matches in both scenarios. Now what if we want to say,
I want a dog and two numbers all after dog keyword. Well, we could use these opening and closing
curly brackets, and we can say two. So this means we're looking for dog string and followed by
number exactly two times. If you read on the script now, and say does not match. If you reduce these
two numbers, there were three file, we run the code is going to say matches, because there are
two characters, which are numbers after dog keyword, you can also extend this by saying
two comma four. And this means we are looking for one to four numbers after the dog keyword,
we can do one to save this didn't say matches. And now if we add nine nine at the end,
we're going to say does not match, because here we have 12345 number characters. If you remove this,
we run our script, we're going to see that this matches. If I would add many space characters,
every script file run the script again is going to say matches, we could inverse this and say
anything that is not a space. So if you run this is going to say does not match. And if you would
replace this with dogs again, we run the script is going to say matches, because we're looking
for dog followed by anything that's not a space. Or we could also look for strings where we don't
care about if they're upper case or lower case. And in order to that, you could use this I modifier
so let me just quickly remove that and change this to dog. Remove this not space character.
Let's save this if I run the script file is going to say does not match. Now this is because we're
looking for lowercase dog. And in this variable, we have capital dog string. If we add this I for
case insensitive, we run the script is going to say match and we can have lowercase uppercase
mixed in here. So let's say uppercase D lowercase o and also lowercase g. If you rerun this is going
to say matches and ignore if the characters are uppercase or lowercase. You can also inverse this
matching meaning we want to check if something does not match your pattern, then we want to enter
the truth. The block for example, if he said this variable contains a cat and instead of matching
it against dog, we want to say if this does not match dog, then we want to execute the logic with
print matches. If he said the script, run it is going to say matches. Now if we add our pattern as
cat, save the script file, rerun it is going to say it does not match because test holds a string
of cats and it does not match a cat because it actually matches a cat meaning is going to print
that does not match. Now another very useful thing, what we can use our captures and captures allow
you to capture patterns in the string. You look at the previous example where we added some numbers,
but we didn't care what number this is. And let's say in our logic, we wanted to actually capture
what numbers followed our string and print them out. Well, we can do something like test,
compare if this equals or pattern, which is cat, add the backslash D for number, plus for numbers
being one or more times, and then we can use parentheses capture pattern we're looking for.
Now the patterns that are being captured are going to get stored in these special variables,
which are door sign one, door sign two, door sign three, so on and so on. But what we could do here
is that if or test matches this pattern followed by one or more number characters, we want to
print out matches followed by the door sign one, because this is our only capture in the string.
If we save this, we run our code, we're going to see matches followed by one, two, three, and this
is what we're printing out in our first capture. You could also capture more parts such as we're
looking for numbers and then let's say space characters. So we're going to have cat one,
two, three, then let's add a bunch of spaces, and then we're going to add how many spaces we
captured in the second capture group. If we print this out, we're going to see matches one, two,
three, and here's our space. Now you can use these regular expressions in loops conditional
statements to capture part of the strings process strings and do lots of cool things with it. Let's
look at an example where a processing list of items and we want to capture first two characters
of each string we're processing. So I'm going to remove this part of the code and I'm going to
introduce a new list which is going to hold the items dog, rat, and cat. Now here I'm going to
use for each loop and we know that for each loop goes through every item in a list and processes
into a code block. I can say my item and I'm going to go through each item in the list I define
above and for each item I'm going to match it against two board characters at the beginning
of the string. So precisely two characters we're using captures so two parentheses and I'm going
to say my capture. So if we run this code we're going to say v o her a and ca. So again with the
final list with three strings dog rat cat we go for each item in that list we're comparing that
item with this pattern which says any word character exactly two times at the beginning
of our value and then we're printing out the pattern we captured which in this case ends up
being d o her a and ca. Now another very useful thing you can use with three jaxes are replacements.
Replacements basically allows you to give a pattern you want to match against and replace
that pattern in the given string value with something else. So let's build up on or give
an example. So I'm going to remove this m modifier and replace this with s which indicates that this
is replacement and I'm going to introduce another forward leaning slash which now here holds the
pattern we want to replace or match against and what I want to do I want to go through all the
items in the list and I want to replace them with the keyword replaced by typing replaced and here
we're not going to capture anymore so let's remove these parentheses let's also remove the anchor tag
and instead of saying the capture because we are not capturing anything anymore so this is going
to be undefined we're going to say item we save this we run our script we're going to see replaced
followed by g t t so it means we went to every single item in this list we looked for anything
at the beginning of the string which is two word characters and we replaced it with a literal which
is replaced and then we printed out the modified item which resulted in these three strings
replace g replace t and replace t again because g t and t now before we move on I just quickly
want to come back to the captures and show you how you can store every single matches against
your pattern into a list of items for example if you wanted to compare our item to a pattern
and capture specific parts of it in a list and store it somewhere what we could do we could assign
all the captures to a list context because every single time a pattern is matched the
reject is going to return all the matches against your given pattern let's see that in the practice
so if i say my at captures now i want to go back to using m keywords
and instead of replacement i'm just going to use a simple match so here i want to capture the first
character and let's say i also want to capture the second character so if we replace item with
dumper backslash at captures which is going to turn this into a reference and it's going to be
nicely printed in the console we run this oops actually we need to compare this against something
because now we're saying all captures is being compared against this pattern but what we want
to do we want to assign all the captures of item to our array we rerun this we're going to see that
every single time we went through the loop we compared for strings and we captured first two
characters so the first capture was stored as an item one in the list and the second capture was
stored as an item two in the list that goes on for all the strings in order to find array which
is called list but what we got captured here is do for dog or a for rat and ca for cat so this
is it for this video we looked at how to use regular expressions in pearl how to capture and
replace parts of strings how to match on patterns and a handful of special characters to help with
string matching do know that what we looked at in this video is only the tip of an iceberg when it
comes to regular expressions there is so so much more to cover and learn it simply would be
impossible to add everything in one video and even with these basics we covered this video was quite
long i do hope you found this video useful and i'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will look at some very useful built-in
pro functions that you will most definitely be using quite often when writing pro code
some of these functions such as delete keys values push shift on shift pop
killer and others we already saw in previous lectures so i won't go into details on them
however and rest assured there are plenty others worth mentioning some of the popular ones being
for example map so what map does it basically executes a code block for every item you give
it for example we could introduce a new array which is called list and what it's going to do
it's actually going to produce a new list with modified items now if we say that my list is going
to contain the cat dog save this and we use a function such as uppercase for uc we can provide
the current item context in the map and the current context as we saw before is defined
by dollar sign underscore so if we save this run our script so pearl script.pl nothing happens
because of course we need to also print or list which is the new list so say dumper and then let's
reference this or easier readability and give it a new list we run the script oops we also add
need to add a semicolon run this again we're going to see cat and dog so all original lists
contain lowercase cat dog we gave our map function a block of code which says upper case every
element you give to this map function which is the list for two strings and produce a new list
which now contains uppercase cat and dog now do take note that opposite to using four loops
if we use map function it's actually not going to modify the items in place if i print out the list
the original list we provided to map function i'm going to see that it still contains lowercase cat
and dog so it actually copies every item and returns a new list in this case we are signing
the list of items to a new array called new list of course we could also modify this further by
saying my item which is a local item uppercasing the current context assigning it to this variable
then let's say we want to append something to the item such as underscore new and then we want to
return the item we're going to see oops actually we need to print out the new list because there's
printing out the original list which as you can see still hasn't changed and we're going to see cat
the uppercase version of our initial string which we then used to append string with underscore new
and then we're returning that item now another useful function we can use is called grep so grep
is kind of similar to map but not really what it does it takes list as well similar to map however
instead of modifying the item in place is going to compare something and if it evaluates the true
is going to return that item to a new list so let's see this by example if i replace map with grep
remove all of this code logic and let's say i wanted to return the item if it equals to cat
so i could use the current context dollar sign underscore equals to cat and basically what you
provide to grep is an expression which when it evaluates the true is going to return that item
in a given list if it's going to evaluate the false it's just going to drop it so if we save this
rerun our script we're going to see cat into the new new list this is because we went through all
the items in the list compared if this equals to cat and if it does we're returning it from the
grep function and it builds a new list we can also say if this equals to cat this being the current
context or the current context equals to dog we want to return it we print this again now we see
cat and dog in our new list because the first element matched from this condition and then the
second element matched from the right hand side condition now another useful function you can use
is called split and what split does it basically takes a pattern and a string and it splits that
given string based on that pattern and returns multiple parts the string was split into so let's
look at example if i say my parts equals split keyword we're going to give it a pattern which
is going to be let's say letter e and we're going to give it a string which is test let's also extend
it with another test for this to become clearer we save this and rerun our script oops of course
we also want to print this out so if he says say dumper and parts save this run the code
you're going to see these parts which is t st underscore t and st so why is that well this
is because we're saying our pattern we want to split on is the e but we don't want to preserve
the e we just want to split on it so basically our string becomes e part one and the part two
is st followed by t up until the second e then the last part which is st your string got split
into three parts by the given pattern letter e now you can also do cool things such as for example
if you give no pattern whatsoever what's going to happen is that your string is actually going to
get split on every single character and sometimes this can be quite useful if you want reverse
strings modify them in particular way or any other scenario but it's just good to know if you
don't give it a pattern with the split function it's just going to split on every single letter
in that string so the next function we're going to look at is called join and join his opposite
to the split so instead of splitting a string into into multiple patterns it's going to actually
join a list of strings into a single string so let's say that we want to redefine all parts
which is going to be both words a b c d e we save this and instead of the parts we're going to say
full string equals or join keyboard followed by string what we want to join on so let's say
underscore and followed by the list so if you replace parts with full string and we run our
code oops actually it's not called list anymore it's called parts so this again we run the code
is going to be a b c d e join with underscore of course you can just apply empty string and
rerun this again and that's just going to be a b c d joined all together some other useful
functions are UC or uppercase that we saw before but we can also use LC for lowercase and we can
uppercase first characters or lowercase first character let's see an example so if i can have
my test equals cat and i want to say that my cat equals you see uppercase test replace full string
with a test variable here this run the code is going to be uppercase cat and we already saw this
before this is nothing new to us however we can also uppercase a cat and we can use LC for lower
case if we print this out again instead of printing out uppercase cat is going to print lowercase
version of the cat because we're running through this LC function now we can also use LC first if
you rerun this we're going to see that it's lower casing the first character everything else is still
uppercase if you reverse this and we have a string which is cat and we say UC first oops you see first
rerun our script and as you might have guessed it instead of the first character being lowercase
it's actually going to be the first character uppercase now what if we wanted to find the length
of the string well we can use this keyword called length so if i assign this to my size and remove
this part and if we print out size we're going to see three so what the length does it counts
the characters in your string so or string consists of three characters c a t so it prints out three
if we say cats and dogs that this rerun the code is going to be 11 characters now we can also use
a function such as rand which is going to give us a random number from the given number to the
function for example if i say rand and give it a number of 10 if i save this rerun the code oops
looks like we're still printing size but we want to print the test variable a rerun the code is
going to give a decimal number and this is where another function could actually become handy so
if you wanted to convert a number without decimal places to an integer you can use function called
int rewrap or random function given 10 with int function and rerun our code you're going to get
six so thing to note is that for example if i give it a number such as 4.5 going to give us four
if i would give a number such as 4.6 it's still going to give us four because what int does it
doesn't give the floor meaning the lowercase version after decimal point or the upper case
it just removes the second part of a decimal number so even if you have something like 4.9999
if you save this rerun it is still going to be four some more interesting functions is you can
use keywords such as sleep so sleep is going to stop the execution of your code for the given
amount of seconds so if i say sleep two for two seconds and then i want to print something like
i walk up and save this and run our code we run it nothing happens nothing happens and boom
we got i walk up printed to our console so sleep subs execution of our code for the given amount
of seconds now going back to strings we can also get substrings of the given value for example if
i say my value equals substring with sub str and then i give a string such as cat and value zero
and one save this and then we save the value save the code run it going to give a letter c you can
see here so what this does the substring basically takes a string it takes the index of that string
and how many characters at that index you want to capture afterwards so if i said one as the middle
number and two as the last number and run the script again is going to print out at and this
is because we're looking at index one which is a and then after that specified index is going to
take two characters which is a t and that is exactly what you're seeing printed out in the
console now you might also be interested in epoch time and to retrieve that value you could let's
say say time so we're basically calling save function value of time function we run this
you're going to see the seconds elapsed in epoch time we rerun this we see this was seven seconds
ago and so on so this is it for this video we looked at some of the more popular functions
used in pro this list is nowhere near complete make sure to check the lecture notes with reference
to resources where you can find more information on the functions we looked at and plenty others
i hope you found this video useful and i will see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will look at some of the special reserve
pro variables and how you can use them we already used some of these variables before such as
regular expression capture placeholders using the dollar sign one dollar sign two etc and the
current context variable written as dollar sign underscore however there are many more to explore
so let's look at some other variables now one of these variables is called argv for argument values
and as you can see this is array and what this value is going to hold are the current arguments
passed to your script through command line so let's print it out now as it is by referencing
the argument values and if we run our script we're going to see that this is an empty list now if we
rerun our script with variables such as one a b or two we're going to see that our list which is
the argument values now holds one a b and two that are the arguments in the exact order we pass to
the script and you can use the arg wall exactly as you would use the list so if you wanted to
access the first item in the list you would use dollar sign argv and access the first value in
the list so what we can see now printed in a console is one because this is a list we're
accessing the first element and it holds a value of one now another useful thing you might find
is using these two dollar signs and what it holds is the actual process id of the script
so every single time you run a process on your system it gets assigned a process id
if you're doing some sysadmin tasks or you want to see if your script is running you can always
check the process id now how we can know that this process id is actually true what was printed
let's introduce a infinite loop so if i say while one do nothing if i run the script
it's going to print the number 9077 which is the current process id and if i open up a new terminal
i could check the current running processes and how to do that you can type ps ox and you can
grep for specific pattern which in this case would be or script name script.pl
and we're going to see that or script is currently running with process id 9077 this is the exact
id we got printed out in the previous terminal window and we see actually two entries here and
this is because the second entry was our grep statement the first process is the one where we
actually have the infinite loop running i have gone back to my first terminal and i have quit
the script that i ran in infinite loop before so we're basically back in the previous state where
we were now the next variable we're going to look at or sign closing square bracket
we remove this infinite loop and if we run the script we're going to see this number 5.036000
and you might be wondering what it is and this is actually the pro version that is executing this
script if i say pro version to see which version we're currently using is going to be 5.36.0
so it might be useful in some scenarios let's explore this array called inc
or includes if i print this out in the terminal i'm going to see a couple of things currently
in this array and what this inc that stands for includes holds is the actual path to modules and
current pro version core modules that we can use in our code and this can become extremely useful
and we're going to see some scenarios in future where we can modify this includes array for
example if we have modules in a different directory we can push new paths to this include array and
pro is going to find them but for now just know that it holds absolute paths of directories where
pro can find modules now the next variable we're going to look at is called env and this is not a
list this is actually a hash so it's written as capital env and it stands for environment variables
if you run our script we're going to see our default system variable which is what is the
home directory is right here and the current language and so on and so on and this is quite
useful if you want to run your script with specific environment variables such as you could do test
env var equals one and instead of printing just all the environment variables we could just print
this one item in the hash which is going to be the test env var save this run our script we're
going to see that war equals to one maybe let's just add something more useful for example custom
string save this and here we see that this environment variable was picked up by the script
the next variable we're going to look at is this standard input so the standard input is basically
just taking the input from your script and we did see it briefly when we were looking at how
to run pearl through command line so if we repeat this through while loop and we use this diamond
operator and we explicitly say that we want to take the standard input and what we're going to do
we're just going to print out the current context which is again accessed by dollar sign underscore
if we save this run our scripts maybe let's run it without the environment variable
so let's try it again and let's say we want to do hello and here we go so we wrote hello and then
we just got the standard input and we printed out hello again and as you saw before we can do
modifications on this input which is uppercasing it lower casing it's splitting it up in characters
so on and so on but let's quit this for now and let's check the next variable which is called
underscore underscore file and two following underscores if we save this run our code is
going to print out script so what the file holds is the name of our script file which in this case
is script.pl we can also use something like underscore underscore line two underscores again
on this and we're going to see ten because we are currently on a line ten and another one called
package if we save this run our script and it's going to give us the main package not very useful
for now but just know that the main package is the current script you're working in when we're
going to be looking at modules this is going to become much more useful because then this
variable references our actual package name since we don't have any package no pro module
it reference our script which is the current main package so this is it for this video we looked at
some of the pros special variables and how you can use them in your scripts as with built-in
functions this list is nowhere complete my suggestion is don't try to memorize all of these
special variables most likely you will only use a very small subset of them anyway you can always
refer to the documentation to find what you're looking for i hope you found this video useful
and i'll see you at the next one hi there and welcome to this lecture it's time to bring out
the big guns and talk about object oriented programming in pro in this video we will explore
what are classes objects attributes and methods and how you approach object oriented programming
in pro to note we will be exploring the built-in pros object oriented system out of the box in this
video however later in this course we will use a module called mouse to create and interact with
objects the mouse module will allow us to build much better object oriented code where we can
introduce attribute types validations and other great features that are not provided by pro's
default object oriented programming approach let's get started first of all what is object
oriented programming well it's a concept that is based on structuring your data and logic in object
each object has properties and methods defined by their classes but the attribute values and
results produced by these methods are specific to each object for example you can define a dog
class and we know that dogs have specific breed height weight color name and other similar
properties you can view these as attributes of a dog class you can create an object of a dog class
and set attributes such as breed equals labrador heights equals 60 centimeters weight 50 kilograms
color golden name feedo so on and so on this specific dog feedo now would become an object
of a class dog you can add methods to your class such as get average speed where you calculate the
running speed of feedo using height and weight it might be a silly method to have but hopefully
it explains of how each method would produce different results for each object of the dog
class if all of this sounds confusing no worries it's a tricky concept to grasp at first but it
becomes so much easier the more you practice object oriented programming now let's look at an
example what we discussed being used in pro now let's start by creating a new file and we're going
to call it dog as we discussed before instead of using pl extension for pro scripts we're going to
use.pm for pro module we're going to write the package name which is dog so technically module
files are not meant to be executable so we don't need to provide our system with indication of how
this file should be run because you don't really execute the module files directly and as with
scripts it's good to return a truthy value and it's especially required for modules because you
need to tell the use directive as we saw before and also this required directive which you're
going to look in next lectures the compilation of this class succeeded and if you don't have
this truthy value in pro module files your compiler is going to complain now the next thing
we're going to use is strict progmas and use warning progmas because we still want to write
better and less error-prone code now afterwards what we're going to do we're going to introduce
a method which is called new now this method is going to receive the first argument as a class
and this first argument is going to refer to the current package name so before the package names
were not that useful when we were working with script files but now since we're working with
modules this is going to become much more useful and in that matter necessary because we will want
to initialize instances of these classes with this package name now let's add some attributes we
talked about before for example breed bite weight color and name and we're going to get all of this
from this argument variable we looked at before so basically this is an array that is going to hold
all of these arguments passed to the new function and the class package name which is basically
dog in this case is going to be automatically given by the pro module file so let's remove that
and the next thing you want to do you want to initialize self and self is just going to be a
hash ref that is going to hold a couple of key value pairs and these key value pairs are going
to be attributes that we're passing to our class at a time when we want to initialize a new object
so for example we want to set the breed to be the breed bite to be bite
weight weight to be weight color to be color and name to hold a value of name that we are going
to be passing to this instance of class dog now the next thing we want to do we want to bless
our instance with this keyword bless by providing self which is the hash ref and the class which is
the last name being dog now basically bless is going to do some inner magic but you can look at
this as that objects in proled are glorified hash refs that have a name assigned to it class name
that says that this hash ref belongs to this class which in this case is going to be dog
and afterwards we want to return self and we're done with constructing and setting the attributes
of this class let's see how we can use this new package we just created let's go back to our script
file and let's try to use it with the same use statement we did for data dumper let's try to
pull in the dog class if we save this and now if we try to run our script it's going to complain
it's going to say that looks like i can't find this dog pm in includes and we looked at this
include global variable before this is where this global attribute becomes useful because now you
can specify additional paths where pro can find this module so for example and we didn't look at
this keyword before we're going to use begin and begin block is basically just telling that this
execution of code has to be done with the before these use statements and again we're going to look
into how use actually works behind the scenes but just know that when you are saying use a module
it's actually running begin block as well and putting it at the start of your script so if
you try to push something on includes array now this would actually get done after we're requiring
our modules but with begin block we're saying that we want this logic where we're adding new
paths to the includes to be done before we are requiring this dog module so i could do something
like push add ink which is the includes and here we can provide the absolute path of the directory
where this module can be found and we can try to discover the current absolute path using our
current working directory or modules but i'm just going to give it an absolute path of the folder
we're currently working from so if i push this to the includes save the file run it again it's
not going to complain because now pro knows from the includes variable where we can find this dog
now if i would remove this begin block and just try to push something on the ink
it's going to complain and this is what i talked about before because use statements are just
using begin blocks behind the scenes so requiring of this module actually gets executed before
we're pushing onto this includes array now that's one way how to use a module an alternative is to
specify additional libraries where you can find modules through command line in this case we could
say roll minus i for includes and dot for the current directory if you run this the script is
not going to complain and if i remove the includes path it's going to complain again and i'm going
to go with the letter approach because it's just easier and we don't need to add extra boilerplate
and we know how to create classes and set the expected attributes and we also looked at how
we can provide paths to tell pro where to find or modules now let's look at how we can get an
instance of this class now to get an instance of this class we can say my dollar sign and dog and
this is just going to be scalar that is going to hold a reference of the dog instance and to
initialize a new dog instance we can say dog or package name and new and this is this method we
created in our package file aka class file and we can see that it accepts a couple of attributes
i'm going to just copy them over place them here so we keep the correct order and set them by
providing these arguments in the new method so i'm going to say that the breed is labrador the
height is 50 let's say weight is 70 we're going to have a chunky labrador color i'm going to say
that it's golden and for name i'm going to say fido and save this if you run our code all looks good
there's no complaints but nothing happens and nothing happens because we're not really calling
any methods or we're not accessing the attributes so let's change that now pro's object oriented
approach out of the box doesn't really come with accessors getters and setters and the getters are
pretty much saying give me the value of an attribute on this instance and setter would do
the opposite it would say set a new attribute value for this instance so let's add some getters
first and getters are nothing more than just subroutines aka functions so we could do sub
let's call it a breed with a function declaration i'm going to say myself equals shift so we haven't
seen shift working on nothing before but basically when you're working on pro you're always getting
the current context when you're calling the method so in this case we could also write shift
the current argument list but in practice you're going to see that usually it's just a shift keyword
now self is something new it's not the class anymore self is actually going to be the blissed
version of the class aka is going to be a hash ref that holds key value pairs of these values so
what we could do we could return self an access key called breed now if we go back to our script file
and here we print something like dog read save this run our file is going to say labrador you
might be wondering but hey can i not access it simply as a key on my dog instance such as read
and if we run this yes yes you actually can but that's not a good practice because you're
actually accessing internals of that instance the proper way how you work with attributes
setting and getting them is through the setter and getter methods which we just have introduced
here because the attribute names can also change or you want to add new logic later on and it's
good to encapsulate your getters and setters in case you want to extend the logic or the attribute
name changes so you don't have to go in every single place in your code and change the value
of that key which is the current self blessed reference now let's quickly add another attribute
getter for example height and i'm just going to return right here we save this go back to script
and we're gonna say height just see that it's working as expected and it does it prints out
50 to the console now what about setters well there's really nothing magical to it they're
the same as the getters they are functions where you are modifying the currently blessed self
reference by overwriting the value so you could say something like sub set height and here you
could expect to receive two attributes yourself and the new height and we're gonna get that from
the argument list and what we're going to do we're going to access self height i'm going to set it
to height and you might be wondering well didn't you just say it's not good to access internals
we're using keys on these hash refs which are blessed selves uh yes it it's a bad practice to
do that but as long as you're doing it outside of the actual class so here we're defining these
methods and attributes inside the class and we're modifying them on the instance so as long as we
are not doing it outside of our class this is perfectly fine so now if i go back to the script
file and before i'm printing out the height i'm going to say dog height equals 70 so note that we
originally set it to 50 maybe i'm going to choose a different number because we're using 70 for weight
i'm going to say 120 and save this run the code and we're still getting 50 and that's because
we are actually calling the getter method so we want to set the height if you rerun this we're
going to see 120 no what about methods well again it's nothing really magical about them
you just introduce a new subroutine aka function so we can add something like sub get height and
weight and again we're going to get self as the first argument i'm going to shift it off
from the argument list and what we're going to return is going to be self height plus self weight
we save that go back to script and let's remove the sitting over height and let's just do this
function name which is get height and get weight so if i call this which is set height and weight
my apologies is not set but it's actually get save this run the script is going to return 120
because 50 for the height and 70 for the weight equals 120 i could change the height to 100
save this again rerun the script and it's going to be 170 now another useful thing you can use
in your classes is this default method called destroy and you write it with capital letters
destroy and here we're just going to print something out like print by everyone exclamation
mark new line and save this if we rerun or script is going to print out 170 from this method and
then it's going to say bye everyone and the destroy method is basically useful for if you
want to do any cleaning up in your instances before they get picked up by the garbage collector for
example if you wanted to do some logging or reach out to a server or anything whatsoever based on
different use cases you can do that in destroy method so object-oriented programming is quite
useful because you can initialize different instances of a class so if i have dog2 and i'm
going to say that this is woodle height is 10 weight is 10 maybe 20 or color something else
that doesn't say just color so white and the name bob woodle called bob we're going to have a
different isolated logic for instance of a class so now if i say dog2 which is going to get a height
plus weight and i'm actually going to concatenate it with dog and i'm going to be cheeky here and
i'm just going to access the key on the instance which is the name because we didn't introduce the
seater method but don't do that a bit of spacing concatenate this and the same for dog2 and let's
change that to dog2 because that source variable name save this run the code we're going to see
two separate calculations so for fido which is the first print statement we get 170 so these
values summed up and for dog2 which is named bob we're going to get value 30 which is these two
values summed up and you're also going to notice that destroy methods run individually for each of
these instances just to quickly mention you could also be passing in named arguments as we looked
at the functions where we were using subroutine signatures or you can pass in hash or a hash ref
instead of arguments in a list it's really your choice so this is it for this video in this
lecture we looked at what is object oriented programming and how we can create objects using
pro's default after the box object oriented system note that we did not touch on inheritance
and using roles to composer classes in case you have heard of these terms these are a bit more
advanced concepts that we will be looking in the future lessons when building classes with mouse
and we'll explore those concepts in more detail there i hope you found this video useful and i
will see you at the next one hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will look at the
difference between require keyword and use keyword in pearl to load modules in your code
now the very basic key difference between use and require statements are that require is for
requiring a module at a runtime and use statement is for using a module at compile time now let me
quickly demonstrate let's try to use a module that does not exist for example i do not exist
and hopefully you haven't installed module with such name otherwise this will work but i will
trust that you haven't if i save this file from the script you're going to see that i do not exist
in includes path and we looked at the includes before and we know that these are all the paths
where pro can look for the modules and if it finds it it's going to include it in our code
and all is going to be well however in this scenario we don't have such module so it's
going to break all the time now let's introduce a logical statement for example if i say if
one is larger than two only then i want to use this module so if i move it down here save the
code and run the script again it's going to complain again and this is because even though
we're using this use statement the logical expression we have to remember that use statements
are always executed in these begin blocks that we looked at before meaning these begin blocks
are going to run before any other logic at compile time and as i mentioned before the
use statement is nothing more than a shortcut or requiring a module which would be i do not exist
now talking about requiring let's remove the begin block and let's change this to require
i do not exist let's rerun our code and this works you might be thinking well maybe this
require actually doesn't do anything and i'm just talking nonsense however if i do remove this
if statement and rerun the code you're going to see that we're all trying to find this module
in our include path and it couldn't now this brings back to the key difference i talked about
so use is always going to be executed at compile time via the begin block and require is going to
be executed in runtime so you can require modules conditionally well you might be wondering why you
would prefer using require over use and vice versa well it depends most of the time you will
most likely want to go with the use statement if you know beforehand that the module being loaded
definitely will be needed in your code however for example there can be times where you work with
data you want to do extra processing on values conditionally if that extra processing logic is
isolated in a module and you don't know if you'll need it then you can require a module during
runtime to pull in the necessary code as we did with example before where we said if a condition
passes we want to require a module which in this case does not exist let's look at other key points
the burning question probably is how does this all work behind the scenes well it's nothing really
magical as we saw before pro has this ink array which stands for includes and holds a list of
paths where pro can find modules now when you use a module for example data dumper as we have been
using it before for pro is going to do it's going to convert the two columns to the path name and
append the pm file so basically use data dumper becomes data forward slash dumper dot pm which
then is being looked at ink folder for all the paths in there going to look for base path and
is going to append the module name which is the data dumper and try to load it from there so if
we explore some of these paths such as here and we have couple of paths so hopefully the module
we're looking for is going to be in the first one if i do ls on this path and if i look here
for data dumper well data looks like it's not here uh let's check the directory before is this
one if we ls this and try to go into data here we go we see data dumper.pm pro retrieves the logic
of this file from this path which is the lib 5.36 the current pro version we're using or higher
depends when you're watching this video and then one further path up and then the data folder and
then the dumper pm but we saw that this path was in or includes folder such as this and the data
dumper was simply appended to it so if we bisect this even further i did mention before as well
that when you use the use keyword what happens is behind the scenes pro is actually calling
require parsing the module name as data for linux slash or depends on your system ending with that
pm so in the end it would look something like this another key difference is that when you
use the use statement it's going to call the module name which is data dumper and import
which is going to get a list of method names you want to import from that module or if no method
names are provided it's just going to export everything by default let's see an example i
just comment this out for the time being and i do use data dumper and i'm going to print out
a dumper and just a string test save this run the script and as expected we're seeing the test
string now if i change this to require it should technically still work rerun the code it's
actually going to complain that pro could not find the method dumper in the current main package
and we know that the main package is referring to the script so basically there is no dumper
method defined in the current package so this is where this import method comes into play
the require by default does not import all the default exported methods and going back to the
use statement and the import functionality you could also explicitly specify that you
want to import dumper method if you rerun this we're going to see that this works as well
and vice versa you could actually provide an empty list and say that you don't want to import
anything if you rerun the code is going to complain again that dumper method could not
be found so that's another key difference when you're using a use statement just remember that
it's always going to get executed at compile time through this begin block and it's going to
convert the module name with the colon colon to the path based on the system and it's going to
require that module and additionally is going to import all the default exported methods unless
as you looked at here you explicitly specify the methods you want to import from that module but
here we're not importing anything at all and we're trying to use a method that actually does exist
in data dumper but it's not being imported or if i try to import something like does not exist
there the file rerun it it's just going to say that does not exist is not exported by the data
dumper module and this is quite handy for example if you only want to work with specific methods
from modules and you don't want to import everything that the module offers or even
further if you want to use the fully qualified module name to call a method such as this
so here it might be confusing because the method is also called dumper but all that's happening
is that we're saying that we want to use from this package data dumper a method called dumper
even though we're not importing it explicitly you can still use it while referring to this module
and to come back to this conversion from colon to path separators you could change this to require
data replace this with forward leaning slash add that pm at the end and try to call this method
again oops we forgot semicolon let's save this rerun it again and it works so here you can see
that we are importing a module based on the path not the package name now the require is also
quite handy if you want to import other scripts because by default you can't use scripts in other
scripts through use command let's look at this so if i remove all of this boilerplate and i'm going
to introduce a new file and i'm going to call this script2.pl now let's add the shebang line
so user bin environment pearl use strict use warnings and it's a good practice to always
write this out let's add the truthy value at the end to indicate to the pro compiler that requiring
of this script file succeeded otherwise we're going to get complaints and let's add a method
such as sub hello from script2 and all this is going to do is going to print here with new line
we save this we go back to the script one and we try to use this script2.pl as i mentioned before
this is not going to work but it says there's a syntax error this could not even be parsed
however if i replace this with require save the file rerun it there are no complaints so now i
can call the method which was hello from script2 save the file rerun the script oops and we forget
the extension so script.pl and we're going to see hey i printed to the console so this is it for this
video we looked at core differences between loading your modules using required and use
keywords all loading modules and scripts work in pro and when you would opt in for one or the other
module loading method i hope you found this video useful and i will see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in previous video we looked at what's the difference between
using required and use keywords we also looked at how we can import default exported methods
from modules or we can explicitly define which methods we want to import such as the dumper
method from the data dumper module now in this video we're going to explore how we can actually
build our own methods we want to export from all modules we're also going to look into what's the
difference between class method and a static method let's get started now let's introduce
a new file and to be precise this is going to be a pro module file and we're going to name it or
module and.pm for pro module and in this file we want to declare the package name which is
our module we also want to return the truth value we want to use strict and we want to use warnings
which is always good practice to do and we also want to introduce a method and let's say this
method is going to be called add nums which is going to take two numbers let's say num one and
num two and we're going to get them from our argument list and what we're going to return is
num one plus num two now let's save our module file let's go back to the script file and let's
try to use our module now let's run the script file let's provide capital i flag for including
module paths which is going to be our current directory noted by.org lining slash and then
we're going to run our script file so we need to save it and if we run this all looks good
now let's say we want to call this function called add nums so i'm going to invoke the method add
nums i'm going to give two numbers three and two and i'm also going to print it out to the console
if we go back and try to run our script file it's going to complain that add nums subroutine is
undefined and that is true because currently we're not importing anything from our module
and this function add nums is not defined in this script file so pearl simply doesn't know
what we're trying to do when we say add nums let's go back to our module file and let's use
this module called exporter that we haven't used before so use exporter we're going to also import
the import method from the exporter now if you remember from the videos before when you're
calling use two things happen pro is parsing your module name by appending.pm at the end of it
you import logic from that module and it's also calling this import method import all default
exported methods so here we're requiring import method from exporter which will be called on our
module to export all the default exported methods so how you define which methods you want to export
is by using keyword or then this array called export where you provide the listed methods you
want to export so add nums in our case if we save this go back to our terminal run the script file
as you can see number five is printed out to the console and this is because now when we're calling
the add nums from our script file this method is imported by default from our module as before if
we said we don't want to import anything from our module rerun the script it's going to complain
about not being able to find a function add nums where in order to call this explicitly we need to
provide a full qualified package name such as our module colon colon add nums and if we run this
this is working again so this is how you can export methods from your module file and one
thing you're going to notice is that previously when we were building our classes and instance
of the classes we got this class keyword which is not the case now nor add nums function and this
is because we're not initializing a new instance of this module we're simply using add nums function
using these two columns so this is called a static method the key takeaway here is that when you're
using static methods you're not getting the class name automatically provided as the first argument
however if we would be needing the class variable in our function we could call it with arrow
notation if we say the script file and go back to the module just print it out so let's print out
the class let's append a new line say the module file we run the script we're going to see two
things all module printed out and then the number five so this was the first print statement where
we automatically got the class name and in our script file we're printing this method add nums
which adds two numbers so there's a difference between instance methods class method and static
method the instance method is called by initializing a new instance from a class where you're getting
the self context the given attributes also the class name and etc and it's being invoked by this
arrow function of course in this scenario we are not actually building the attributes in the self
and we're not also blessing the self hash ref with the package name however we're still getting the
class name as the first argument since we're invoking it with an arrow function and that's
why it's called the class method now the final method which we called initially was with these
two columns we would save this rerun the script what you're going to observe here is that actually
number three was printed out and then a warning about trying to use uninitialized num two in
addition in our module but what happened now is that the first two arguments which are class
and num one were taken directly from our script file as the arguments we passed here so we're
never getting the num two as the third argument and instead we end up printing out the class name
and trying to add num one variable which would hold number two in this case and then adding number
two variable which currently is undefined now to quickly go back on the export methods alternative
of using this at export array you could use export underscore okay and if we remove this class name
and print class name and just return the sum of two numbers we go back to our script and let's
also remove the package name and save this file run it through terminal we're going to see that
add num's function was undefined actually we also need to remove the port forward or explicitly not
importing it save this rerun it again and we're still seeing that warning and the difference here
is when you're using export as we did initially without the underscore okay all the methods in
that array are going to be exported by default when you're using underscore okay appended to export
these methods are not automatically imported meaning you need to explicitly import those
methods you're exporting from your modules if i save this rerun the code it works again so this
is it for this video looked at how to use exporter what's the difference between export and export
okay and we also took a step back and we looked at what are instance methods class methods and
static methods now when you use each is really up to you and the use case by the end of the day
really depends on scenarios what you're trying to achieve sometimes you just want to encapsulate
the logic which does a very simple thing such as add still numbers in that case you don't really
want to initialize a new instance of an object and you can simply use a static or a class method
to do anything that doesn't require a self-context now when you need a self-context to access
attributes that have been initialized by creating an instance of a class then you would use an
instance method and access the current self-context but again it's really up to a use case and it's
up to you when to use the different accessors at different times i hope you found this video useful
and i'll see you at the next one hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will
look into how we can install pro modules using cpanm aka cpan minus the pearls package module
manager before we begin i would like to know the pro actually already comes with package manager
called cpan that is without an m at the end so this begs the question why would we be using
something that's called cpanm instead of the default package manager well think of cpan and
cpanm being exactly the same they both are needed to install and manage pro modules however the cpan
m requires no configuration and is much less noisy in comparison to cpan when installing modules
also it is incredibly easy and quick to install cpanm when using probrew so there's really no
reason why not to get it on your system now to install cpan on your system you want to go to
your terminal and you want to type probrew and what are you going to get is a bunch of commands
related to the probrew pearl and so on what you're interested in this case is a command
that says install cpanm so let's run this so if i copy this command and type probrew
followed by install cpanm run this it's literally going to take a split second for cpanm to be
installed in your system or you can verify that this is running you can do which cpanm and this
is going to give you the absolute path to the cpan binary and that's it easy as that we now have cpan
m on our system which is going to be automatically initialized on a new sessions we're now ready to
install some pro modules now how you can install modules is by typing cpan minus minus help to get
a manual page and here we can see to install module we can simply run cpanm and the module name
which is going to install module on our system now there are other options you might want to run
your installation with which is this verbose option that kind of tells you more information
of what's going on when you're installing a module you can also force install modules in case there
are some dependency issues but you're fairly certain the module is going to work anyway
and usually when modules are being installed they also run tests and you can specify a flag
not to run those tests and you can also install modules from a file which is quite handy because
you can keep track of all of your modules in a file and then run cpanm install depths and provide
a cpan file which has all the modules that needs to be installed and there are others to explore
but we will focus on the simple command which is cpan and the module name to install a specific
module the official pro module repository is located at metacpan.org so let's go there before
searching google metacpan i'm going to see this link which is metacpan.org we go there you're going
to notice that it's quite minimalistic and it's straight to the business let's say you're met with
a single search bar and you can use this to browse the massive module ecosystem let's say i wanted to
find a module that can help me with converting between json string to hash ref structure and
vice versa so what i could do i could search for json and on what i'm going to see here are a couple
of options presented to me it might be overwhelming at times and you might not know which module to
pick but most times you can simply choose a module which is at the top of the list and if you want to
find more information about that module you can of course browse the name of it see how much is
being used to understand if it's the best fit for the job now if i select the json access i'm going
to be taken to the documentation and usually the module documentation on metacpan is excellent
it gives you some examples of how to run this module general description any pitfalls so on
and so on it's always good practice to read the documentation to understand if the module you're
looking at is actually suited for the job in this case at the top of the page i can see those two
things it encodes a json and supposedly it provides a json text and it also decodes a json
text and provides a hash ref or array ref well depends on the json structure but at this point
i'm fairly certain that this is what i need now to install the module let's copy the name
let's go back to the terminal and simply run seep a name and then the module name
which is json colon xs so i run this this is going to take a couple of seconds to install
and that's it it shows that the module has been installed on our system well to be more precise
it's installed into location where the probe room manages all the modules installed for the current
pro version we're using through the pro brew so again this is why the pro brew is quite useful
because it keeps the things isolated from each other now if we go to our editor and let's say
we want to use this module now how you do that is by using this use keyword that we explored before
and then the module name which is json colon colon xs and we can save the file if we run this
with pro script nothing happens this is because we are using the module we're not getting any
complaints that this module could not be found but we're also not using any functions from this
module so let's go back to the documentation and here we can see that we can call encode json
which we don't need to explicitly import from json xs by copy this name go back to the script
let's try to print out a hash ref that is a value json structure for example if i print
dumper and i'm going to wrap around the encode json function and in this encode json i'm going
to provide an anonymous hash ref i'm going to end this with semicolon and let's say i want to encode
a key which holds value one and b key which holds the value of two if i save this run the script
and here we go we can see that this is a string printed or terminal with two keys b value two
and key a with value one now the documentation also states that we can decode json so let's
try that if i copy this method name go back to the editor and instead of encoding a json
i'm going to use decode json now here what we can do we can copy the string which we encoded before
and provide that instead of a hash ref structure we save this run our script is going to convert
from a json string to a hash ref structure so by now you probably have noticed that array refs and
hash refs are quite similar with the structure of what is considered the value json so if i wanted
to decode for example json array that holds a simple string a save this go to the console
you're going to see that this is converted into array ref with a single value of a that's quite
easy by nature to convert between pro data structures and json structure now you're probably
wondering how can you find installed modules on your system strangely there is no straightforward
way to do it one of the options is to use another module which is called ext utils installed and
this module is going to give a list of modules currently installed on our system so if i go to
the documentation and look for ext utils colon colon installed which is the second option copy
the module name go back to the terminal if i say cp name install this module we're actually going
to see that this is one of the core modules so you don't even need to install it so if i go to
my editor and use this module by ext utils colon colon installed it has a method which is called
modules that we need to call on a new instance of this ext utils and it's going to return a list
of module names so what we could do we could print dumper and inside the dumper function
you could say ext utils installed new we're initializing a new instance of this class and
we chain a method on this new instance called modules if i save that go to the terminal run
the script here we go we see a couple of installed modules in our system now that we don't see stuff
like exporter that we looked at before or data dumper and this is because this module does not
list the core modules of pro it only lists the ones that we have installed on the side it's still
quite handy utility to know what's installed on your current pro module path this is it for this
video we looked at where to find and install pro modules i hope you found this video useful and
i'll see you at the next one hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will explore a
better way of handling exceptions in pro using two modules triton is smart catch an exception
class instead of using evil and die functions as we saw before first of all why would we want to
use modules to handle exceptions instead of using the good old baked-in error handling a pro well
some very valid reasons would be that maybe you would like to execute some additional logic in
your code when a known exception was thrown or you might want to log exceptions with different
priority based on exception type for example if a user enters invalid password when logging into
your app you might want to throw invalid password exception and of course there's plenty other
scenarios using die and evil and maybe some rejects could achieve this organization of
error layers but trust me that would be a huge mess real quick and by the end of the day we don't
have to do it because we have some very awesome tools at our disposal as i mentioned before the
first module is called triton is smart catch and it basically allows you to catch errors
in different blocks by package name rejects exact errors and handle unknown exceptions
the second module is exception class this module allows you to create custom named exception
objects with attributes and other goodies that massively allows you to enhance the management
of errors let's start by installing these modules now the first thing you want to do you want to
go to meta cpan and what you want to search for is try tiny smart catch so if you open it up
you're going to be presented with quite detailed documentation and i highly suggest you to read
through it to understand bits and pieces that maybe we will not touch on in this lecture and
that stands for every module if you don't understand something or you would like to try
additional functionality it is highly encouraged to check the documentation for the time being
let's copy this name triton is smart catch and let's go to our terminal now i'm going to use
my editor's terminal to install this module so cpan name and the module name and it was pretty
quick to install now the next module that i mentioned was exception class and it's written
as exception colon colon class so here it is in first suggestions again as before you can check
the documentation if you want to find out more before time being let's just copy the module name
let's go back to our terminal and let's install it as well this is going to take a second or two
to get installed and i'll see you once it's done now the modules are done installing and we are
ready to use them in our code however before we proceed i would like to have a quick refresher
on how we throw and handle errors in pro so if you remember we used this keyword
called die then followed by a message for example i can type this is it
and if we run this and maybe let's add a print statement if we say something like
hello save our code go to console run the script and we're going to see this is it without hello
being printed out now if we use the evil keyword and wrap around or die statement save this
we're going to see hello printed out because the die was handled and to print out the error we
can use this special variable with dollar sign add symbol if we save this we run our code we're
going to see that we print hello and in this variable we have the exception that was thrown
and also it indicates on which line it was thrown in our script now this is the old way let's see
how we can handle errors in new way but first of all we need to use both for modules so let's do
that the first module is called try tiny smart catch so use try colon colon tiny
on colon and smart catch and the second module is called use exception class
now let's start by handling exceptions with try tiny smart catch what you can do you can
tap keyword try followed by sub and you can put your code in here in between this try sub block
now to catch general errors we can use this catch default followed by sub
and all the errors that are going to be thrown which we do not handle in a specific way are
going to end up here for example if i say error that we receive is in this local context denoted
by dollar sign underscore and here we control for example die this is it if we save this
run our code and looks like we forgot one of the columns so exception colon colon class
we rerun this and what we're going to see is this is it which is exception to the code on line 14
now this doesn't seem really useful at this point i mean we are throwing errors we're just catching
them by default so what's the big deal with this now the real power comes with using these in
conjunction with exception class now how you construct custom exceptions with exception class
is by you provide a list context and you define your new exception for example my exception and
we can see this here in the construct let's give an example so all we need to do this we also need
to wrap it as a string your exception name has to be a string another question is how do we use them
well you use custom exceptions by writing my exception or however you named your exception
and calling a method which is going to be inherited from the exception class called
throw and here if you look at the documentation you can throw exceptions with specific messages
so what we could say is for example error something is not right now if we do this save
the code we run our script we're going to see something is not right printed to the console
okay you might be wondering right we're throwing custom exceptions now uh but there's not much
difference so i still don't see the point of them well we have to go back to the tritany smart catch
and explore the documentation there if you look at the documentation you're going to see that
you can actually catch specific exceptions so for example here we can write something like catch when
exception name and the subroutine let's do that after our try block and before the catch default
which is the handler or or unknown exceptions we can write something like catch when then the
exception name in this case this is my exception followed by zero notation which takes subroutine
and here we can do something like say i know this exception exclamation mark now if we set the code
we run it and here we can see that we actually printed out i know this exception instead of
just falling into the catch default block now imagine in your code you have different scenarios
such as you could not connect to a database or you could not parse a json where a file system
is full or so on and so on maybe these are exceptions you want to recover from in that case
you can add as many catch when blocks as you want for example my exception and let's replace
it with something like app file system full copy this exception add it here and let's quote it
and now instead of saying my exception throw we can do app file system full and throw and we can
say something like oh no the disk space is full exclamation mark let's introduce two scenarios
for example if you use a conditional statement like if now i'm going to say this random which
we looked at before five is larger than two then we want to throw this exception else we want to
throw my exception throw an error something else instead of here we could actually print out
exceptions themselves i'm going to replace these maybe i'm actually going to put them in a string
context so we have a better visibility instead of the full stack trace so let's wrap this context
with string as well and if we go to our terminal run the code we're going to see something else
let's run it again still something else oh and our exception changed because there's a chance
that if this random number is larger than two we're going to throw this specific exception
otherwise we're going to throw the my exception so here the first two times we threw the something
else and the third time we actually threw the disk space exception that says the disk space is full
hopefully you do agree that handling exceptions this way is much much better approach and gives
you much more flexibility than just simply putting die statements in your code and trying to reject
specific exceptions we're not going to go into too much detail on this however just know that
in our exception class we're not just restricted to saying error something you can also add our
own attributes that we can get on the current context of a known exception do some additional
logic but now what i'm demonstrating here is that when you throw specific custom exceptions
you can handle them in different ways in very trivial approach that is just so much better
than throwing exceptions in the default pro way now this is it for this video we looked at how
we can do much better exception handling using triton a smart cache and exception class modules
instead of the out of the box die and evil functions i hope you found this video useful
and i'll see you at the next one hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will
look at how we can make web requests and parse responses using mojo user agent first of all why
are we using mojo user agent just to clarify there are definitely other modules in metasipan
ecosystem that allows to make and parse web requests however i find mojo user agent to be
very user friendly and feature rich and this is what a modulicious framework is using behind the
scenes there's definitely a solid choice mojo user agent includes some off-grid features like
parsing various content types for example json to hashref ending and receiving data via web sockets
and probably one of the most awesome functions async requests using promises if you come from
javascript background you might be very familiar of these however if not in summary promises are
not blocking async tasks you put in background while running your code and they will resolve
so to say once the task has been completed if it does not make sense no worries we will look at
the basic example in a minute now as before where you want to start you want to go to metasipan
and you'll want to look for mojo colon colon user agent so if you open this up as before the
documentation is quite good here and it gives you a lot of nice examples of how you can run them
with promises in async even how to use web sockets and running multiple requests in parallel but one
step at a time let's start by copying the module name going to our terminal and installing it so
as before stepan m and the module name and we're going to hit return this is going to take a minute
or two and i'll see you back when it's done installing now the mojo has done installing
and we're ready to proceed running some web requests so where do we go from here well as
before we want to start by using the module so use module user agent and let's save our file now
let's go to our browser and what i'm going to be using is this website called json placeholder
typecode so basically what this website is it just kind of gives you these mock responses
in a json format and this is exactly what we want to do we just want to test simple web requests
using get to fetch some posts for example so i'm going to be using posts and we can see that if we
access posts we're going to get 100 items and we can also access specific posts before slash one
four slash two and so on let's copy this link which just accesses the first post and let's go
back to our code now here i'm going to declare a variable i'm going to say my post and i'm going
to set it as a string and here i am just pasting in the link we just copied from our browser now
how do we call this url well we need an instance of a user agent and as you know from before you
get instances from classes by calling method new but what we can do is we can say my ua for user
agent equals module on colon user agent arrow notation new and now we have access to functionality
of this module on this instance now let's see how we can make a get request if you go back to
documentation we're going to see that in order to get data we need to call method get followed by
the url and we also need to call result so let's try to do that if we print something out from
ua arrow notation get followed by the link which is stored in our post variable and then call
result which is result semicolon go to our terminal run our script url script.pl it looks like we actually need this
additional package to be installed in order to run secure requests so since we're calling
https we need iosocket ssl to be installed on our system so let's run cpanem iosocket ssl
let's wait for this to finish installing right and this is perfectly normal this is actually
great that we're getting these errors because now we can look together into how we can resolving
these dependencies now let's see if we can install this module so if we do cpanem run net ssl
wait for this to finish installation and looks like it failed again perfect i mean this happens
all the time and no need to be scared for throwing the towel and give up so let's look at the build
log so i'm going to print this out what's in the build log it's going to say i could not find lib
ssl headers and looks like we're actually missing open ssl require files in our system in order to
install this package if you do get an error about not being able to install that ls module and if
you're on mac what you want to do you want to run this command you can see in the terminal which is
brew install open ssl and that should take care of all of the dependencies needed for that module
so i already have it installed and i sanity checked if everything is working and it is and hopefully
it's going to be working for you as well however if you are on a distribution like ubuntu what you
want to do you want to run this command which is sudo apt get install lib ssl dev right so hopefully
the installation finished for you without any issues let's try to run our script again and i
did not install the full module yet we run the script and yes it says that iosocket ssl is missing
so if you rerun the installation so cpn m ssl run this let's wait a minute and that should be
fine and i'll see you back once it's done all right so the installation finished for me without
any issues and hopefully it's the same for you but if you're facing any difficulties whatsoever
please do leave a comment and we can look into it together right after all this hustle let's go back
to our script and let's see if it's working now so pro script.pl if you run this what are we going
to get right so we see that this is actually an instance of an object but here we're printing out
an instance of something and something being message response now the question is what are
we missing to actually get the body of the response well if we go back to the documentation
we can see here in quickjson api request basic authentication we don't really need the
authentication part but from the example below we can see we're calling results that we are doing
in our code as well but it looks like we're not actually calling json method it seems that when
we're calling results we're getting back an instance of response and there's also a method
to request a parse json body so let's do that let's call the result and arrow notation json
say that try to call the mock IPA again and we're going to get hash well this looks better because
this is actually now a hash ref but that just means we want to print this through dumper because if
you're just printing a hash ref we're going to get the reference in memory as we saw before so that's
why we need to use the dumper first time the charm here we go we got back a json body which
was parsed into a hash ref and this looks all good you can use other potentially quite useful
methods on the result itself instead of just getting the body directly for example i could
save the result into result equals you i get post result and without calling json let's just say
some stuff such as result is success and also let's copy this line and call this method
code which is going to give us the status code and let's save that rerun the request
if only i could spell success we're missing one s save that rerun the request and here we go we
can see that this request was successful because we got a truthy value back and here we can see the
hctp code for the successful response which is 200 and you're not just limited to get requests
you can use put requests or the post requests you can submit form data or you could submit json
data depends on your use case which exactly type requests are you looking for and examples here
are really great you can find a blueprint for pretty much anything you want to do with module
user agent now let's look at something more a little bit advanced talked about these promises
the beginning of the lecture i did mention that promises allows us to make many requests in
parallel without blocking the execution of our code let's put that in a practice and see if it's
really true now if we remove this print part and just simply try to get the same url couple of
times let's see one two three four five six seven eight nine ten so if we do this we're going to
reach out through this url ten times in a sequential manner right so this first request
has to reach to succeed the second request has to succeed third one and so on let's run this
and let's also remove the variable names because we don't really need that we don't want to store
results we just want to reach out to these urls and see how long it takes to time something you
can use this system time command so let's use that before pro and run our script right it took
eight seconds for me to call ten urls for the post one might be faster for you might be longer
depends on connection but average for me is eight seconds my net is not that great i think that is
quite true but the question is how we can improve this well if we go back to documentation which is
again pretty great when it comes to showing examples you can see that there is a comment
saying concurrent non-blocking requests synchronizer promises well that looks promising so let's keep
in mind that we can call the same methods as we did before we get but we just need to append
underscore e for promise now let's go back to the code let's replace this example with something
else i'm going to construct a couple of promises that we want to resolve in a synchronous manner
in our code but what i'm going to do i'm going to declare a new array called promises i'm going to
call a map function and i want to call this map function from one to ten elements basically this
is going to give us a new list for one to ten items depending on what is returned in the map
function so in the map function i'm going to do ua user agent get underscore p for the promise
and here what i want to do i want to copy the url that we called before which is the posts with
number one i could of course append a different post number using the current context by source
and underscore but i'm not going to do that because we did look at example using the post
id one it's only fair that we use the same ids so now how we can actually get results back from
these promises you need to use another module and this is going to already be installed when
you install mojo user agent it's one of the dependencies and it's called mojo on colon
promise what this module takes is a list of promises and how you construct this is mojo
promise error notation all where you provide the promises and then you type then and in that then
function it expects a function so sub this is just anonymous subroutine there's nothing really
special about this we're not assigning it to anything we're just providing anonymous subroutine
and what we can do here we can get all the promises that have been resolved in a list but
we don't actually need the parentheses since we are accepting the list and we're going to get
this in the argument list and we have seen this many times before and this list is going to be
populated by this then method but the question is what are we actually getting here in this
resolved we're going to be getting back the response object exactly the same as we did get
from calling the get link once so we had to call the result and then we had to request decode the
JSON body what we could do we could say dumper i want to say this for every single result promise
which is the response we can use a loop which is four same as with if conditionals we can use some
of the loops after the declaration of our code so here i'm going to say for resolved and what
i want to print out is the current context which you're getting from this loop each item in resolved
as i mentioned this is the response but it also contains other elements in this result so i'm
going to access the first item in the resolved list the result JSON and save this if you rerun
our script with time function we're going to see that we have a syntax error this is because we're
missing a semicolon after then block so let's add a semicolon we run this and looks like nothing
happens this is because we are actually missing another call after then chained function call
if you look at the documentation what you also need to do we need to call the weight to await
our promises which we are not doing let's add this weight all as well let's chain it after then
and rerun our script hey looks like it took only four seconds from doing all of these calls
sequentially one by one so we literally reduce the time to make these requests by half which is
amazing so this is it for this video we looked at how we can make web requests using mojo user
agent parse a request response check the status codes and do some very awesome things like making
multiple async requests using promises i hope you found this video useful and i will see you at the
next one hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will explore how we can write
and read files in pro using out of the box tools and we'll also look into using pro module called
path tiny which gives a nice and easy to use interface to work with files however let's start
with looking into how we can write and read files using solutions given by pro now to write a file
you can use this open function and this open function takes three things it's going to take
a variable which is going to be a file handle and the next is going to be a symbol that indicates
if you want to read a file append a file or overwrite existing file content now here what
we can do we can try to write something to a file to our current location from where we're
running the script and i'm going to call it test that text let's end this line with semicolon now
the first thing you usually want to do you also want to call the close statement on the file
handle but you don't want to end up having multiple open file handles which can lead to memory leaks
that's a good practice to always open and close your file handles even if you want to move them
to different lines later on it's just good to have it there for visibility and a reminder
now let's end this line and now to actually write something to the file we can use print
and instead of just printing something like hello rolled to the standard output we can
actually provide a file handle and what's going to happen instead of printing with the standard
output we're going to print to this file handle which is going to write something to our file
if we save this and run our script nothing happens but that is good because we're also
not seeing any warnings however what we're going to see that there's a new file next to our script
and this file is called test dot text quite conveniently the file also was created at a time
of being written to but we didn't have to take care of that if we open this file we're going to see
hello world now let's say we want to write multiple lines what i'm going to do i'm going
to copy these print statements a couple of times save the file run it again and if i go back to
test dot text file i'm going to see multiple lines linked to the file now what if we actually had
something in the file already let's say i already exist and saved in our text file go back to our
script and we run it again and let's go back to the file to the test dot text what we're going
to see is that what we had originally in our file was actually overwritten and this is because when
we're using this greater than symbol what's going to happen is the content of that file is going
to be overwritten we did see many hello world lines but this is also because we are working
with a single file handle so everything is written to that one file handle which is then
saved to this file now that also means that alternatively we would need to read the file
contents in reprint them to the file and then append the other lines we want to write to it
but there's an alternative what you can do you can use these two greater than symbols if we save
this and i'm going to add newline character at the end of our hello world lines and if we go
back to the test file and let's reintroduce something like i already exist if we save that
go back to our script rerun it and if we see or test the text file now what happened we actually
preserved the original content so that's the difference between one greater than and two
greater than symbols so if you're using one greater than symbol it's going to override
the contents of the file however if you're using two greater than symbols it's going to append to
the file and that's exactly what happened here so we already had a content and we just appended
our new hello world lines now the question is how we can actually read the content of a file
it's quite similar to writing to file but we use less than symbol and how we can store the content
of the file we can declare a new variable for example my content equals and we haven't seen
it before but we can also use this do block and what the do block allows you to do it allows you
to define the logic you want to execute very similar to function but the difference is that
do block is actually going to turn the value at the end so here we want to return all the content
that we read in our file so how we can do that is by saying local polar sign forward slash end this
line and then we provide similar to taking an input what we saw with the diamond operator
instead we can define that we want to take the input from this file handle which we opened before
on this line now if we print out the content to say content save the file run the code again
we're going to see all the content printed your console now let's quickly explore what is going
exactly here we have this local door sign forward slash in file handle to put it simply we are just
setting this real special variable to undefined and we're setting it undefined locally in this
do block scope if we wouldn't do that for example if i remove local
lower sign forward slash and rerun the code we're just going to see the first line that we have in
our file which has already exists and hello world that we can see here now the reason why we want
to localize this variable and set it to undefined is because otherwise pro is just going to read
the input up to the first break line and it's going to stop reading the file if we set this
special variable that indicates the end of the line to undefined is going to read all file you
might be wondering well why can't we just set this variable to undefined in general for example
before the code such as this variable equals undefined and if you rerun this it does work but
the problem is that we are affecting the scope of this variable if you want to read different
lines of code or if we wanted to take input from the terminal this means we have modified this
special end of the line indicator because we're setting the scope globally all we want to do
by setting this special variable to local in this do block scope to be able to read contents only
of this file specifically without modifying the special variable end of the line indicator
globally and this is how all of this comes together here in this do block we define logic
that we want to execute in isolated scope in this scope we'll localize the end of the line variable
to be undefined meaning we want to read the full file content which is currently held by this file
handle and we can do this by telling pro that the end of the line separator should be undefined
meaning read in all the file and also as i mentioned the difference between if conditionals
and the do block is that the do block returns a value at the end of the execution so meaning is
going to return all the contents that was read in from this input to put it simply we're just doing
this to be able to read in the whole file through this file handle we opened up on this line just
above the do block now there is one pitfall reading in contents of a small file is perfectly
fine through this approach however if you have files that go into hundreds of megabytes or even
gigabytes do note what we're actually doing we're reading the file and the memory so this might not
be the best approach you want to take if you are dealing with huge files what you probably want to
do you actually want to read the file contents line by line and in order to achieve that you
can use the while loop so let's replace this do block with while and what we're going to add in
this while loop expression is going to be defined keyword and here what we're going to do we're
going to say my line equals current line from the input of the file handle now what we could do then
we could define a new content variable with an empty string and here in a while block we could
say that we want to append to the content with dot equals the current line and then we want to print
out the content if we save this we run our code we're going to see that the content holds all the
lines we read in and appended to this content variable alternatively we could instead print
line and the current line we're iterating over if we save this and remove the content variable
and rerun the script we're going to see that we read in each line and we printed it out followed
by two new lines because the lines we have in the file ends with new line and then we're saying
something which also adds a new line and this is excellent approach in case you want to parse large
files line by line and honestly that's probably the approach you want to take most of the time
instead of reading the whole file in one go right so this is it for this video we looked at how we
can read and write files in pro using out of the box solution we know how to write to the files
append to the files and read the files however in the next lecture we're going to explore alternative
and that alternative is using a module called path tiny which gives you a very nice interface
to interact with all of these actions where you want to write read append to files and you don't
need to think about these internals of localizing things and keeping of state and so on because
that's all managed by the module i hope you found this video useful and i'll see you at the next one
hi there and welcome to this lecture in the previous lecture we explore how we can read and
write files in pro and that's perfectly fine to use the out of the box approach for trivial tasks
read or write to files however you might have noticed that there's a lot of low level things
you need to keep track on in order to take the out of the box solution when it comes to managing
files such as you need to create file handles remember symbols for writing reading and appending
to files closing file handles and so on it should be much better if you could delegate these low
level tasks to a module that can do repetitive steps for us and it turns out there is such a
module well several but we will explore one of the most popular ones called path tiny path tiny
gives us an excellent and easy to understand interface to do all the actions we did before
it's light fast and in my humble opinion very user friendly when it comes to working with files now
first things first in order to use path tiny module we want to install it and as before we can go to
metacpan module repository and look for path colon colon tiny if you open up the link as before we're
going to be met with great documentation and it's going to give you many examples to achieve exactly
what you're after even in the summary we can already see some examples of how to read and
write to files and not just that we can also read directories which is pretty great so let's
start by installing this module if you copy the name of the module go back to the terminal and
as before run cpanem the module name it's going to take a second or two to get installed and i'll
see you back once this has finished now the module has finished installing and we're ready
to use it in our code and in order to use this module we can do the same thing we have done
before so we use the use keyword path colon tiny which is this module's name and what this module
exposes is a method called path and this path method takes a string where you provide the file
you want to read or write to in this case i'm going to provide a file which is called test
dot text and i'm going to use the relative directory you could use the absolute directory
to indicate where you want to read or write the file from but in my scenario i want to work with
a file which is relative from where i'm running the script which is currently pro underscore
course folder and next to the script.pl file and what this path method returns is an instance of
a class that is going to have various methods that is going to allow us to read and write files so
what we can do we can say my path and assign the return value to this path variable and if you
don't know from where this path function is coming from i do encourage you to check the video where
we talk about the difference between require and use keywords and how some methods are automatically
imported by modules now returning back to our example what we could do now we could do path
and color method spew if you go back to the documentation we're going to see that in order
to write files we can call the spew method that takes a list of data we want to write in this
example we could provide a very simple list for example three strings that says a b and c if we
save this file run it oops looks like we have a syntax error and yes seems like we're missing
semicolon at the end of this statement so if we add a semicolon we run the file we're going to
see that there's a new file that appeared next to our script file which is called test.txt and
it contains three things it contains a b c now here you can see that we actually wrote separate
lines and you would be expecting that it's going to write the lines line by line in the file but
this is not the case you do need to provide the separator explicitly for example if i replace the
single quote characters with double quote characters and if we save this and also let's
add a new line at the end of each character we run the file and let's see what's in the test file
now we're going to have a b and c on new lines so do keep in mind that you do need to provide
new line separator when you want to write your data on separate lines now alternatively if we
wanted to read a file what we could do you can use a method called slurp and how we do that is by
declaring a new variable we're going to store the content of the file and i'm going to call it a
content and assign the result of path slurp there this we run the code and we probably actually
want to print out what's in our content variable if i print out the content save the file and we
rerun the script again we're going to see a b c and this is the exact content that we have in our
file now alternatively you could also use a method which is called lines so instead of just reading
everything in in a scalar context and just having one string we can use lines that we assign to
content which is an array and here we can print out the dumper backslash reference of the content
just to get a better representation of what's in this array we can just turn it into array ref so
if we go to the console and rerun the script file what we're going to see is that we have each line
read separately and it ends with a new line you could of course do some processing you could remove
the new line but if you're happy to leave it as it is then just know the lines do read a file line
by line by preserving the end separator of that line now you can do other very useful things with
this module and i do encourage you to check the documentation there's an excellent documentation
of each of the methods you can use to achieve things such as modifying the permissions of a file
or moving a file from one path to another this module also allows you to work with directories
and list files and directories and so on by the end of the day this module pretty much allows you
to do anything you would like to do with files folders reading writing files moving files
modifying permissions working with different paths so on and so on now this is it for this video we
looked at alternative of how we can read and write files using a module called path tiny instead of
using the pearls auto the box solution to work with files i hope you found this video useful
and i'll see you at the next one hi there and welcome to this lecture in this video we will
explore how we can run system commands through pro there can be some cases where you want to
do some sysadmin tasks that for example requires you to list files run some commands or maybe you
want to create your deployment scripts and you want to execute some delete commands so on and so on
as always scenarios depends on the use cases now the good thing is that pro allows you to call
system commands and it actually allows you to call system commands in three ways one way is
where you can actually capture the output of the system commands you run in pro script the second
is that you can run a system command without capturing output and maybe you want to just
execute command and quit your script afterwards now let's explore the first scenario where we can
run a system command and capture the output of that command you can invoke a system command by
using two backticks for example here i can say ls for list and i want to list files in a current
directory what i could do i could say my output equals the result of this command if we run our
script now if you also print the outputs of what was stored in this variable so say output
and run our command we're going to see script.pl so it listed and printed out the files currently
in our directory if we did that in our terminal with ls and the current directory we can see the
same thing now we can also make this a little bit more useful and before outputting the contents of
the of our directory what we could do we could say run system command which is going to create
a file in our current directory which are going to call based on this context.txt file for each
list of numbers 1 to 10 so this should create 10 files the names from 1 to 10 and append text to it
if we save this and rerun our script we're going to observe two things that 10 files were created
in our current working directory and also we got the output from this list command i also talked
about alternatives of how you can run system commands if you might not care about the output
there's a keyword you can use called system so what system takes is a list of commands you want
to execute as strings so for example we could say ls and the second element is going to be the next
argument we want to run with the system command and this would be equivalent of running ls space
dot forward slash so if we save this and let's actually try to capture output of this and this
equals to our system command and if we print this out by using say output and i'm also going to
interpolate this in a string which i'm going to add to output save this go to the terminal run
the script what we're going to see is that we actually get all the contents printed out
to the terminal but do take note that these contents do not come from the variable of output
that we're printing here what we're getting in the output variable is actually zero and zero
indicates a successful execution of this system command now the system command was actually run
in a child process the contents of what we see here in our terminal were printed out separately
so that is a key difference between using backticks and using system command when you do care about
the outputs and saving that to a variable you can use two backticks and provide the command there
if you don't care about the output you can use a function which is called system and you provide
all the arguments in a list context now i also talked about the third way which allows you to
execute command and quit after execution so let's try to do that and it's very similar to system
command but what you do you type exec and let's still try to assign outputs of this exec command
and let's try to print it out if i clear my terminal save the script file and let's run
our script again so pearl script.pl what we're going to observe is a similar behavior to the
system command we got the output printed out from our child process and it's still visible in our
terminal however we're not seeing anything printed out after we run our exec command and that is the
key difference when you run exec is going to execute command and quit the script so all the
code you write after that command is simply not going to be taken in account so nothing is printed
to the terminal so you might be wondering which command you would use when again as always it
depends on scenarios you might want to list all the files and parse the output from the system
command using the backpacks to for example get all the file names you might just care about running
the system command in background and continuing your execution of the script without caring about
the output or alternatively you might want to run some specific output in a use case where you don't
want to execute any follow-up code if for example some conditional statement was true it really
depends and it's always up to you which use case you'll find the best fit for the job so this is
it for this video we looked at three ways how we can run system commands using backpacks system
keyword and exec keyword i hope you found this video useful and i'll see you at the next one